[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
this is a very special edition i am in
the cave
of peter tia dr peter tia and we'll get
back to his bio in a second
we have the incredible videographer
who is trapped inside a closet to
monitor
levels everything has been fitted to
perfection
and that all makes sense shortly dr
peter tia who can be found at peter
tia attiamd.com is a former ultra
endurance athlete so imagine swimming
races of 25 or so miles maybe more
a compulsive self-experimenter emphasis
on compulsive
and one of the most fascinating human
beings i know he is one of my go-to
doctors i would say
the go-to doctor for me for anything
performance or longevity related
but here's the official bio to do him
some justice peter is a physician
focusing on the applied science of
longevity
his practice deals extensively with
nutritional interventions
exercise physiology sleep physiology
emotional and mental health
and pharmacology to increase lifespan
that is how long you live
while simultaneously improving health
span in other words how
well you live peter trained for five
years at the johns hopkins hospital in
general surgery where he was the
recipient of several prestigious awards
including resident of the year and the
author of a comprehensive review of
general surgery
he also spent two years at nih as a
surgical oncology fellow at the national
cancer institute
where his research focused on
immune-based therapies for melanoma
he has since been mentored by some of
the most experienced and innovative
lipidologists endocrinologists
gynecologists sleep physiologists and
longevity scientists in the united
states
and canada peter earned his md from
stanford university and holds a
bachelor's of science in mechanical
engineering and applied
mathematics peter also hosts the drive a
weekly deep dive podcast
and i do mean deep dive focusing on
maximizing longevity and all that goes
into that
including physical cognitive and
emotional health it features topics
including fasting ketosis
alzheimer's disease cancer mental health
and much more
you can subscribe on apple podcast
spotify overcast or wherever you listen
to podcasts
you can find him all over the interwebs
peteratiammd.com
on twitter petertiammd instagram samsam
petertiamd facebook you got it petertia
md and then on
youtube peter tia m d
peter welcome back to the show wow that
was
quite an intro it was an incredibly
comprehensive i could have shown up a
little later
so we've we've uh we've had frequent
flyer miles
uh on on podcasts including on this show
and last time we used a format that i
quite enjoyed in part because it
required minimal preparation
for me and that was going through
categories
excited about changed mind about and
stupid things or absurd things that you
do and i know that you have
a number of things that you are excited
about
so we may spend more time in that
category uh
so why don't you kick us off well um
so yes so so the nice thing about this
is i get to prepare a little bit and i
jotted down a few bullet points on each
so um
i think one of the things i'm really
excited about is a very recent thing
and that it's come to market really
recently it's been in the works for
about five years and it's something
called a liquid biopsy um
and the reason this is interesting is
that when you think about the sort of
major chronic diseases
which is the diseases of atherosclerosis
so heart disease stroke
cancer and alzheimer's disease we don't
have a lot of great tools at detecting
cancer early
so cancer screening is a somewhat
controversial topic
most people are probably familiar with
things like mammograms colonoscopies and
psa testing
um there are two or three others that um
rise to the level of having
evidence to suggest that we do them for
example pap smears
um but when it comes to some of the
really bad actors of cancer
we don't really have great screening
tools and so what a liquid biopsy
does is it draws a sample of blood
and through that tries to predict
whether or not you have cancer
cells in your body and tries to do so of
course when you have very very few of
them because the evidence is
overwhelming
that all things being equal a cancer
when caught early at an early stage is
imminently more curable than a cancer
caught at a later stage
and probably the most compelling
explanation for that is that the longer
a cancer gets to fester in your body
the more chance it has to develop
mutations and the more mutations
it generates the more difficult it is to
target later on
so there are a number of companies that
have been doing this
but to me the most interesting by far is
a company called
grail because of the method that they've
gone about doing this
and the method is using something called
cell-free dna
as opposed to tumor dna and just for
those listening
grail is in holy grail exactly
coming out big as a little side note
grail was recently acquired by
another company called illumina illumina
being the largest company that does dna
sequencing
and a very interesting note is the ftc
has sued illumina for anti-trust
violations in this
acquisition which if you understand the
science of it and we don't have to get
into it in great detail
um is literally the dumbest thing i've
ever heard so that the ftc
has done this in my opinion is actually
a tragedy because it is actually going
to cost
lives it's going to cost tens of
thousands of lives in delay
if this acquisition does not go through
because illumina has the power to scale
this up
like no other company would putting that
aside for a moment
um what is what is cell free dna because
that's really at the heart of this
say that one more time what is cell free
dna cell
free dna cell hyphen free yeah as in dna
that's not in a cell so most of the dna
in your body is contained within
cells um but when a cell breaks
down or sometimes even when
cells spontaneously like red blood cells
or actually typically monocytes white
blood cells
make dna and then spontaneously
like release it from them you can
capture these small amounts of cell-free
dna so if you
draw somebody's blood whether or not
they have cancer or not they're going to
have
a certain amount of this cell-free dna
floating around
you have signatures on dna called
methylations
a methyl group is just a carbon with
three hydrogens on it it's one of the
most basic
building blocks of organic chemistry and
as dna
acquires these signatures so remember
dna is made up of these four nucleotides
when they start binding these little
methyl groups actg
exactly actg as they start acquiring
these methyl groups
that tells a bit of a story and
even though there's not a lot of cell
free dna
when you look at it the best analogy and
one of my analysts actually came up with
this analogy is it's sort of like
looking at you know meteor fragments
that would land in the desert
and being able to understand what type
of an asteroid they came from
so even though the asteroid is enormous
and it shed
like big chunks of meteor down to earth
and by the time they actually hit the
earth they're just small rocks
a chemical analysis of that would give
you a greater idea where it came from
so this type of test can actually detect
up to 50 different
types of cancers there are certain ones
that it's not very good at detecting
such as prostate cancer
which is not bad because we have other
tools that are so good at detecting
prostate cancer
but when you do this blood test you
basically get a readout which says no
cancer detected
or the following have been detected and
it does this
with about a 50 sensitivity and about a
97 to 99
specificity now to explain what that
means in context
requires a little bit of math and it's
worth going into
so sensitivity is the
probability that a cancer is truly there
if detected by the test
and specificity is a problem is the
probability that the cancer is
not there if not detected by the test
so sensitivity speaks to true positives
and specificity speaks to true negatives
now at first 50 sensitivity doesn't
sound that good
but you have to remember it depends on
what we call the pre-test probability is
so pre-test probability says what is the
probability that you have cancer before
i test you
and that's a function of many things
it's a function of the prevalence of
that cancer
it's a prob it's a function of your age
it's a function of other behaviors so
for example
two people being otherwise identical
except one being a smoker and one not
being a smoker are going to have very
different pretest probabilities
but when you start to think about for
example you what's your pre-test
probability of having
pancreatic cancer it's quite low
fortunately even though pancreatic
cancer is one of the most lethal cancers
out there
so in a low probability environment
a modest sensitivity of 50 and a very
high
uh specificity produces incredible
what we call positive and negative
predictive value
so what do those things mean so positive
predictive value as it sounds
means what's the probability that if you
get a positive test
you truly have cancer a negative
predictive value
is of course if you have a negative test
what's the probability it's negative
these numbers end up being well north of
90 in fact the negative predictive value
is about 99.7
the positive predictive value is in the
ballpark of about 97
so these are really exciting tests
especially when you
pair them with some of the other things
that we do in our practice
such as relying on a very special type
of mri technology that uses something
called diffusion weighted imaging
that adds sort of a functional dimension
to mri
quick note there people can if they
really
want to deep dive into that subject
matter
you have a guest on your podcast and
i've listened to this episode it does
get quite technical but that's right
what is the guest name for people who
want to want to search
raj r-a-j and how do you spell his last
name
a t t r a a
w a l of course i can't spell in my head
but if you just search
raj mri it'll it'll pop
up um and yes that's that's an episode
we usually make our patients listen to
before they go and get one of those mris
so they understand it
follow-up to that unrelated but uh
related to grail
what is it that happened or
what technology was developed that
suddenly made this possible where it was
not possible before
or what realization why did this
suddenly come to fruition
or or only now become available
i think the major insight and i will be
doing a podcast on this but i need to
wait until this ftc issue is resolved
a little bit because the person that i
really want to interview for the podcast
who is one of the people that had the
biggest hand in developing this
is actually now the chief scientific
officer at illumina
and so for him to be able to speak about
it obviously it would need to make sense
that illumina actually owns the
technology again
i would say and this might change as i
get deeper into understanding
their journey i think it was the
realization that tumor
that tumor dna was not the place to go
so
at the outset of this process people
didn't know what to look for would you
look for rna of tumors
because rna is the you know it's the
template that's telling you to make the
protein
and that didn't really pan out because
rna is so unstable
by itself so then pivoting to dna the
logical choice was well let's look for
the tumor dna you know if you have
pancreatic cancer and we can find
the dna of a pancreatic cancer cell that
would be a good place to start
but you have to be looking for cell-free
dna by definition
when you're doing a liquid biopsy
because you're not going to sample the
organ
and it turns out that tumor dna
represents about 0.1
of cell-free dna so i think the big aha
for grail
was realizing no let's look at cell-free
dna which is much more abundant
but instead look at the methylation
patterns and then specifically figure
out what those methylation patterns were
so that was the real puzzle
yeah the the forensic science yep that's
very cool
i don't know if if i interrupted a train
of thought that
had more to say about grail do you want
to to say more about grail or do you
want to hop to another yeah no i mean i
just think that this is
you know i i'm i have been waiting for
this like i said for five years
um because i think that i'm just less
bullish on the idea that we're going to
quote unquote cure cancer
right if you put cancer in perspective
the overall survival for people with
metastatic cancer
has improved about five percent in
50 years and virtually all of that
improvement has come
with a handful of very specific types of
cancers
so for example something called the gi
stromal tumor
and a certain type of testicular cancer
for which there's been like
you know very specific behaviors of
these that have rendered them
quite sensitive to certain
chemotherapies but
when it comes to you know lung cancer
when it comes to pancreatic cancer
when it comes to colon cancer breast
cancer once
you don't catch it early you're sort of
in the same situation you were in about
and that's that's pretty depressing when
you consider how much progress has been
made in cardiovascular disease since
that time
so i think the answer in how do you live
longer with respect to cancer
is prevention well it's both right it's
so what can we do to prevent cancer and
not smoking and being metabolically
healthy are hands down the two biggest
things that you can do
and then the next step is how
aggressively can you screen
and stack different levels of screening
technologies on top of each other
so that you know the way we kind of
describe it to patients
is you want to think of like the swiss
cheese approach right you want to be
able to stack a whole bunch of things on
top of themselves
so that you just get only one pencil can
fit through
yeah each each method or technology in
of itself having gaps
that's when you lay them on top of each
other hopefully
the the the remaining gaps are
sort of allowable if that makes any
sense absolutely and it's exactly that
it's basically how do you use
multiple technologies to cover the blind
spots of others
i'm excited about grill also because it
seems like especially if
scaled through illumina the ability to
have grail
widely distributed makes it
just by definition more available at
least as one tool
compared to say the mri that we were
referring to right
earlier which would appear to be site
specific i don't know yeah
mri is going to be far less scalable um
and
and frankly far more of a hassle i mean
if you've i don't know if you've ever
had well you haven't had one yet we got
to get you up there yeah
i've had for better and for worse
probably quite a few mris uh
not always in ideal circumstances but
this particular mri not yet yeah
um yeah so it's like how do you drive
the cost down how do you improve the
technology how do you make the algorithm
better and better and better because it
is under under all of this is a huge
engine of machine learning
that makes it better over time so you
mentioned in terms of
prevention metabolically healthy is
there anything you're excited about or
would like to
underscore that relates to developing
metabolic health or improving metabolic
health
always um i'd say
you know exercise is so important right
it can't be
overstated it's potentially one of the
most
potent drugs we have but all exercise is
not created equal i would imagine
correct
for this purpose absolutely um and so
i think of exercises having four pillars
and um you have to be strong on each of
those so if you're
strong in three but not in one it's sort
of like a table that has three legs and
not one it's still a reasonable table
but it's not as strong as a table with
four legs and a table with two legs is
pretty pathetic and obviously a table
with one leg is
not a table so the four pillars are
stability strength
aerobic efficiency and anaerobic
performance
and i think that most people understand
loosely what three of those are could
you say those all one more time
sure stability that's the one that most
people don't understand we can talk
about that in a minute
strength aerobic efficiency
and anaerobic performance so
i guess we can unpack all of them but
stability is the ability to
safely transfer load from the outside
world to the body and vice versa
which sounds sort of like a i don't know
kind of a
soft explanation um an analogy that i
really like
using is that of a race car versus a
street car
so what makes race cars so unique
is that and why by the way a race car
that's got half the power
of a street car will still knock its
socks off on a track
is because the chassis and the tires of
the race car
are constructed in such a way that every
bit of that power is making it to the
road
so the analogy i like to think of is
that the tires of a race car are like
our feet and stability really does begin
with the feet and most people myself
included when i was starting
had horrible proprioception with our
feet
you know we don't really know how to
load our feet correctly and a lot of
that
comes from the fact that we wear shoes
all day your hands and your feet are
actually very similar and if you think
about what you can do with your hands
how easily
you can move them around spread your
fingers sense
pressure in different areas most people
can't do that with their feet
and that that comes to comes to bite you
so
um as you think about how it moves up
the the sort of chain
um a very common problem
is uh the which i think accounts for
probably more of the injuries that
people experience
is this pattern where the pelvis is
tilted forward
the ribs are flared up the erector
spinae muscles in the back are sort of
locked
short meaning they're locked like
they're locked in
concentric load and the hamstrings are
locked long so they're locked in
eccentric load
yeah it's how someone who's quite lean
from a body fat perspective can still
look like they have a
pot belly that's right with that
anterior pelvic tilt
which actually so so you've asked me a
question i think that i can answer this
with there are really two things i'm
excited about that
pertain to exercise and i'll go down
this path and then we'll come back to
the other one
um so what's the what's the ideology of
that
position which i was the king of that
position
um it's probably what do you mean by
ideology
like where did what drives that why
would a person show up with that posture
of
ribs flared up pelvis tilted forward
back tight hamstrings tight and long
besides wearing six inch stiletto heels
which i never wore i mean i wore them
sometimes but i don't often wear them
you're in good company judge your hoover
and all
so it probably starts with lousy
respiration
and and i'm not exactly sure why that's
the case but
i i think somewhere along the way we
stop learning
or we stop breathing correctly into our
abdomen right so we
instead of breathing the way we should
breathe which is the diaphragm should go
down
the abdomen should come out the pelvis
should actually
fill with pressure we tend to breathe
using ex so that's those are the primary
muscles of respiration as a diaphragm
we start using accessory muscles like
the pec and the pec minor
and we kind of lift the chest up this is
a very
common pattern of respiration and i
think it's that
lifting of the chest that is what's
bringing the rib cage
up and when that happens the body
is a little bit out of balance meaning
your center of mass
shifts forward and the body senses that
and in an effort to prevent you from
falling forward it's basically
tightening those erector spinae muscles
it's it's
pulling you into balance again but in
doing so
it's creating this downstream problem in
the hamstrings
which is they're just they're locking
and
if there's another thing i've become
really obsessed with it's hamstring
control
which is different from hamstring
strength a lot of people
myself included can have very strong
hamstrings i used to have incredibly
strong hamstrings
if you put me on a machine and made me
do something in isolation
but i could never recruit them so a
simple exercise to demonstrate this
which beth lewis had me do for the first
time maybe two and a half or three years
ago was
laying on your back with your knees up
and your feet down so you're sort of in
a
back position knees up you know feet on
the surface of the ground
and without letting your back tilt into
a huge
you know make a huge dome underneath it
so while keeping your lower back flat
can you with one leg pull
very very hard back to your butt and
feel your hamstring tense so that is
a very specific manner of recruiting
hamstring strength and believe it or not
i couldn't do that
with that while keeping my back down my
back would i would arch
like a cat if i tried to do that there
were many more of these types of
exercises
but it was through this type of very
deliberate
you know starting on my back and then
learning to do hamstring recruitment
while standing
and while feeling pressure in my feet
that
really allowed me to get back to dead
lifting with
a feeling of safety that i'd never
really experienced because i used to
deadlift so heavy when i was young
and basically got away with using my
back to dead lift
which is obviously not what you want to
do and then i just started having
nagging injuries as i got older so by
the time i was in my
mid-40s i'm dead lifting and it's like
oh my si joint would bug me and after
i'd finished my back would just feel
tight
um so it's sort of you know what age
sort of
exposes your deficiencies and eventually
everybody's going to sort of pay a price
for this
some people do these things naturally
better than others so i think there are
some people who can kind of go their
entire life
lifting heavy weights without having to
pay much attention to this stuff but you
know i certainly wasn't one of them
does that type of training that you're
describing that
progression kind of starting back from
the foundation or the fundamentals does
that have a particular name
the there are a couple different schools
of thought that have been implemented
into this training one of them being
dynamic neuromuscular stabilization or
dns
which is heavily focused on this ability
to find the breath and generate
you know this concentric abdominal
pressure so creating a cylinder inside
the abdomen
as opposed to like an upside down
triangle where you
have some pressure up here but none down
here
and then another school of thought
that's been heavily influential here
has been something called postural
restoration institute or pri
and that's that's really the one that
has focused on this idea
of how do you correct what from the side
looks like this right you know sort of
pelvis down
ribs up and how do you fix that position
and
and um again it's it's it's hard because
it requires fixing everything from the
feet
to the neck how much of a contributor if
at all do you think
extended sitting is to that
configuration
with the kind of flared ribs up and
anterior pelvic tilt if any i think it
probably
is um and and probably for a couple of
reasons
you have to sort of think about it as
the positive and the negative right so
one drawback of sitting is that you're
not active
so it's it's simply the removal of
active time that is a problem
and i think the other problem with
sitting is it is simply harder to
generate
um intra-abdominal pressure and it's
easier to just rely on these accessory
movements of respiration to lift up so
you know i if i think i've said this
once before like if i could be czar for
a day
you know i'd go back to kids when
they're in school and you know have them
in standing desks or
squatting those would be your two
positions right so you either
you're kind of squatting to do work or
you're standing to do work but you're
not sitting in the types of chairs that
we sit
in i think i have an idea for a
complimentary short form podcast for you
which is just called czar for a day
five minute five minute commandments
from zaratea yep and more more barefoot
time
that's another thing right you know with
my first two kids
i wasn't so aware of this when they were
young and now with my youngest who's
almost
four like i study this guy like he's
like the master his his movement
patterns are simply unbelievable which
of course
all four-year-olds should be i just
never noticed it before
but the manner in which he moves and
lifts himself
and reaches for things and sits around
it's incredible it is
it is such a spectacle to behold uh so
you know if you if you spend more time
watching your children and that's you
know dns
is modeled on exactly that right dns
basically says it grew out of something
called the prague school in
czechoslovakia
which was originally
looking at ways to take children with
cerebral palsy
and teach them how to move again by
realizing that what cp had robbed them
of was a lot of the developmental
movement patterns that occur in the
first two years of life
and once they started to realize you
could actually take these kids
and retrain their neurologic system to
do things
in a more functional way that you could
actually do this as a form of rehab
and then ultimately a form of prehab
which is sort of how i like to think of
it now
so i've seen uh i don't know how much of
this is public
but incredible results
from a trainer also world record holder
or former world record holder in olympic
weightlifting jersey gregorik
working with a number of
clients or patients with cerebral palsy
using very incremental
movement rehabilitation and training i
mean the the before and after
differences are staggering and it's it's
it's i mean i speak to probably my
ignorance of cerebral palsy but
just never was even within my like
conceptual schema that
that would be possible it's very
exciting to see so um
speaking of exciting oh so the other
thing on exercise
to get back to your question about the
metabolic stuff is
you know about three years ago i was
becoming more and more
interested in this idea of zone two
training
uh which has a very technical definition
and then we can explain proxies for it
but the definition of zone two
is the highest level of output you can
produce while keeping lactate below 2
millimole
so lactate is a byproduct
of anaerobic metabolism so when we're
sitting here at rest our lactate levels
probably one
if we're metabolically healthy there are
some people who sit around at rest
higher than two um but if anybody's done
lactate testing knows you know
as you start exerting yourself more and
more your lactate will rise
and you know peak levels in highly
trained individuals can reach
above 20 millimole and that's
accompanied by
remarkable discomfort actually so
um i've always done lactate training
when i was you know
being an athlete which i haven't been in
forever
but i was never focused on this aspect
of it i was always focused on something
called lactate threshold
and peak lactate so peak lactate for me
was kind of a marker of just how much
pain i could endure
and lactate threshold was a marker of
the highest amount of
output i could produce for relatively
short races
um like you know meaning short for me
would be like half an hour or something
like that so knowing my lactate
threshold was important for that stuff
but this zone two stuff is way below
that
right zone two is by definition your
all-day pace
it's basically at a lactate level of two
you should be able to
go all day because that's the that's the
level at which you do not net
accumulate so you're producing but
you're not accumulating and so it's the
rate at which
clearance equals production and you stay
at that level of two
so does that training fall into the
aerobic efficiency category
exactly just a very quick note
to say that we really nerded out on zone
2 training with peter we got deep into
the rabbit hole it got very
very dense also actionable but i moved
that section to the end of the episode
so if you want to check that out later
continue listening now back to the show
so
you mentioned fat utilization or the
ability to use fat as a substrate
are there things and specifically what's
coming to my mind such as
fasting or intermittent
ketosis that help you to use
fat in such a way that it transfers to
zone two training
is there any crossover i suppose yeah
well there's no question that
you know ketosis by its very definition
is a nutritional state that forces your
body to utilize
fat um and depending on how much you're
in taking some of that fat could be
endogenous so again
exogenous is the fat that you put in
your body so what
fat you eat is exogenous the fat stores
that we have are endogenous
there's a bit of a i think just a
misunderstanding around ketosis i think
a lot of people assume it is
automatically a weight loss
diet or a fat loss diet but of course
that's not necessarily true
it's only a fat loss diet if you use
your endogenous fat stores
also turns out a pound of fat has a lot
of calories yeah
so um you know i could gain weight on a
ketogenic diet if i ate enough
right now the the advantage of ketogenic
diets for most people
is that they're quite satiating and you
don't want to
eat endless amounts uh in the way that
if you went on the all dorito diet
which i've also pioneered i've got
experience with the all dorito diet
and uh turns out you can eat a lot uh
the all licorice
i used to work at a video store when i
was in high school called movies and
munchies
and you know it was owned by
my friends the video store plus
dispensary
yeah and they didn't they just didn't
care how much i ate
yeah and i would literally eat
the pound of twizzlers like you know
they came in that pound maybe a pound
that happened it was like the biggest
bag of twists you could take out like a
mugger with this bag of twizzlers
yeah yeah exactly like it's a weapon and
if if any reasonable group of four
people went to a movie they'd have a
hard time finishing one but i would
easily throw that down
plus the really big bags of doritos plus
a really big bag of popcorn plus
god knows what else like that was
routine for the night
just disgusting easily four or five
thousand calories of junk food
three nights a week was my stay so if we
look at the opposite of that
fasting has you have you changed your
mind or had
any insights since we last spoke or come
to any different conclusions related to
fasting yeah i mean i think because
you've done
i mean for the record you've done you've
done a lot of fasting i mean you have a
lot of experience doing
fasts of many different lengths
including i don't know what the longest
fast is that you've done
probably ten days ten days yeah um
yeah i think that you know one thing
that i absolutely learned through
fasting
uh is the the the enormous importance of
strength training throughout a fast
it's very easy you're going to lose
muscle mass when you fast you have to
accept that
so the question is how do you minimize
that damage how do you lose as little
muscle mass as possible and
strength training daily during a fast
has become an important part of that
but when you look at time restricted
feeding which is
or people call it intermittent fasting
although i don't i don't like that term
very much i think time restricted makes
more sense when you're just talking
about you know 16 or 18 hours
um i i i'm really starting to see a lot
of people who do that excessively and
who aren't necessarily training
correctly
they lose weight but they're losing
muscle
more than they would want to see and you
know
we just had a patient who we did a dexa
scan on last week um
and it was probably the first one we've
done in 18 months on him
and in that 18-month period his body
weight had not changed maybe he was a
bit lighter actually he might have lost
four pounds
but his body fat was
so high i almost fell off my chair and
he doesn't look
chubby right but he's it speaks to how
much muscle he's lost so he
his body fat went from about 18 to 30
percent
yikes which was you know it's just a
totally unacceptable amount of fat for
someone his age
um and and his visceral fat went up
which i actually care more
about than body fat we can talk about
that later um
but his visceral fat also went up so you
know this is a guy who has religiously
been doing his time restricted
feeding every day but he doesn't really
lift weights you know he
he walks and you know does some yoga and
stuff like that but he's not doing
strength training so i think in a person
like that
there's a real downside to too much time
restricted feeding
and even for myself like in the last
four or five months i've been i
you know i did a dexa back in january
and i hadn't done one in
years and from the
from january to the last period that i
had done a dexa
my body weight was almost identical
maybe i was two pounds lighter this year
versus the
last time but my body fat was up
i think i went from 10 to 16 body fat
and again you could say well 16 is not
the end of the world but you know that
was a significant loss of muscle and
gain of fat
um and i i did wonder if that was just
too much because because i always
exercise in the morning but then don't
eat
so you you know to exercise and then not
provide yourself
with especially with when you're
strength training to provide yourself
with any amino acids
every single day to you know undergo
muscle protein synthesis
i think it's a little bit risky so so
i've been looking at other strategies
around that right so for example
front loading the meal question when and
then we'll come back to front loading
meals during that period of time
were you doing and this i may be
misremembering
but one one three day fast a month or
one
week long fast every quarter what was
the
frequency all of the above yeah i
probably spent
maybe two years doing seven days a
quarter maybe a year doing of three days
a month
um and then but in between it's also
doing lots of time restricted um
and honestly i think the daily time
restricted was a bit
more the issue because i think you can
you relatively
you can really you know i think the
three-day fast a month
with a lot of lifting i didn't sense i
lost a lot of muscle
during that period of time but i think
every day
exercising in the morning not putting
calories in until later in the day
it has to be it has to be taken in the
context of an individual so
if you're someone who's 100 pounds
overweight or you have diabetes
it's a totally worthwhile trade-off to
lose muscle mass
because you're losing more fat mass
along the way yeah right so you are
going to technically get leaner with
that approach but when you take
a relatively healthy and lean individual
um
one has to be a little bit careful and
look for alternative ways to
sort of get the benefits of that fast so
you were saying something about front
loading meals
yeah so i just find nowadays uh although
probably not tonight
um i'm i'm i'm gonna eat almost
certainly not tonight
uh i'm gonna eat a little bit more early
in the day and a little less
late in the day so there may or may not
be some mezcal involved
there will be so we won't take either of
our aura ring data
as the standard for this evening uh so
so i i totally got caught up in my own
fantasy so front loading meals can you
just walk back and expect in an ideal
world i think that the best way to do
time restricted
eating would be to eat a big breakfast
so would be to wake up
exercise eat a huge breakfast
by huge i don't mean gluttonous but i
mean that's your biggest meal of the day
that's a i don't know let's just put
some numbers to it you wake up at six
you work out from seven to eight thirty
at nine o'clock you're eating your
largest meal
you eat another meal at 1 o'clock that
is modest and you don't eat again
that would be a great way to do 16 hours
of not eating a day
that's problematic for two reasons the
first is it's socially problematic
it's really easy to not have breakfast
because very few people eat breakfast
with other people
but dinner is our social meal and
for obvious reasons this just poses a
difficulty to be the guy who never eats
dinner
the other i've been just as a side note
i've been at
multiple dinners now having quite a few
actually
where you've been fasting and we've all
been sitting drinking
wine and just like pass the cheesecake
at the end and you take a big whiff
and then continue moving it along it's
entertaining
but it is pretty anti-social yeah to be
that guy to be that guy
um yeah drinking the soda water
and then the other thing is i think for
many people it is hard to go to bed
hungry
um and truthfully in longer fasts it
gets easier because
you know if you're fasting for seven
days by the time you hit that fifth day
your a lot of your hunger has sort of
dissipated but
16 hours of not eating can generally
pose some hunger and for some reason i
just think psychologically in the
evening we're a little less busy
so it's even more noticeable whereas if
you're
doing the traditional way that people
think about not eating for 16 hours it's
pretty easy to wrap yourself up and work
in the morning
skip breakfast and kind of delay your
lunch a little bit
so you know i don't know that i have a
great answer for that other than i think
people should be
a little cautious and not just apply the
same hammer
uh to to every nail and kind of think
about their own physiology a little bit
and and rely on these
you know technologies like dexa to make
sure which again is so
so readily available relatively
inexpensive um
and and provides both good information
about body composition and also
this thing of visceral fat that yeah
well let's we'll come to the visceral
fat
in just a second uh on the dexa note
about
i don't know a year and a half or two
years ago
uh i recall a conversation with
a dexa technician
who said to me over the last 12 months
i've seen
many cases of people coming in who
are newly avowed intermittent fasters
who have had their body composition flip
basically i mean like
not necessarily flip but the
they've had massive jumps in the
percentage body fat
and i i put that on social as a
as a note not not to say that all people
who do time-restricted feeding
experience this
and it was hilarious and
also uh frustrating to see
how many religious zealots there are
around
intermittent fasting who are just like
bite thy tongue you know but wait wait
but you said that
according to this tech that they got
better intermittent fasting or worse no
they got worse
they got worse met with what i'm
describing it's exactly
it's exactly compatible with what you're
saying yeah but there was a lot of
resistance
to the idea that that would even be
possible
right uh which which i found
really interesting more social
commentary than anything else
and i think it just speaks to sort of
why i don't like talking about nutrition
very much because
it it does lend itself to
politics not literally but it's sort of
the politics religion
ethos which is whatever you're eating is
obviously the only thing and um
i guess i just encourage people to be
much more attuned to all of the tools
right so caloric restriction dietary
restriction
time restriction right you've probably
heard me go on and on about my framework
the three levers um
always pull one sometimes pull two
occasionally pull three
never pull none so time restriction
what we're talking about restricting
when you eat but otherwise not
restricting how much or what dietary
restriction
uh is restricting some of like
some of the content in what you eat so
not eating carbs not eating wheat not
eating meat
eating doritos right not eating sugar
those are all forms of dietary
restriction
um and then caloric restriction is
restricting the amount
and so if you are never pulling one of
those levers
which means you're eating as much as you
want whenever you want of
of you know whatever anything you want
anytime
how much whatever that's called the
standard american diet
sad yeah the sad and we've been running
a very good natural experiment on that
for 50 years and the data are in
so it turns out that less than 20
of the population probably less than 10
of the population
is genetically robust enough to tolerate
the sad
um so it's a great piece of data like
there are people out there who can
you know eat kfc and doritos
and pizza anytime they want
and they're generally okay to a first
order approximation i would add that we
don't really know the answer this
question
because we don't have super granular
data at the population level
but notwithstanding that at least at the
surface level
it appears that 10 of the population are
largely
um you know immune to the sad but for
the rest of the 90
of us schmucks which i'm certainly in
that camp
the sat is lethal and so you've got to
come up with a way to
you know escape the gravitational pull
of the sad
and that's why i think having these
three levers at your disposal
is is the key and yeah i think that
what happens is people get so into the
camp of their lever
like it's all-time restriction or it's
all dietary restriction not too many
people are in the all-calorie
restriction group
there's a whole calorie restriction
society and there are so there certainly
are people that are in that camp
um but it's usually the first two camps
that have the the most zealots
levers i was waiting for the canadian to
come out
i must love those levers ah sorry i'm
sorry i'm very sorry
i'm so sorry
[Music]
i also think i i said bite thy tongue i
don't practice my older english much i
think it's thine
tongue but i'm sure the internet will
correct me
quick uh tactical question and then i
want to ask you about
any research or studies that have been
interesting to you
that have come out since we last spoke
uh
is it effective or have you tested
using small amounts of branched-chain
amino acids
to mitigate the muscle loss during
what we would otherwise consider fasting
and does that affect does that
also if it has any effect uh
lessen the benefits of the fast it
depends on what you're doing the fast
for
i think if you're doing the fast for
weight loss then the answer is
absolutely knock yourself out with
branched chain amino acids during
strength training
because from a caloric perspective they
represent such an efficiency yeah
yeah like even if you were to double up
on
you know my favorite bcaas which are
biosteel
you know you're what are you going to
get in there 40 calories in two servings
right so
not an issue if you're doing the
intermittent fasting would
call it the hope of achieving some
amount of
the early signatures of autophagy then i
would say that it probably
is counterproductive because the amino
acids that you use
in exercise are exactly the ones that
are the most potent stimulators
of mtor and the whole purpose of fasting
at least in the short term
is to give mtor a rest it's to take away
that which it senses
and it is the most potent sensor of
leucine which is the most important
branch chain amino acid
yeah so if so if i could dumb that down
for myself if you are interested in
the longevity benefits of
fasting aside from just getting too
healthy
body composition you should not take the
branched chain amino acids
it seems to me it would i mean i can't
say anything with certainty but it seems
counter-productive yeah yeah
got it all right studies any papers or
studies
that you found interesting oh my god
so many there's a lot if you if you had
to cherry pick
a few well look i think the recent new
england journal paper that you and i
have talked about
is very interesting comparing lexapro to
psilocybin
um i wrote about it recently and
um my little diatribe basically said i
think the
paper was in some ways misinterpreted um
it was positioned as a negative trial
though i saw it as anything but a
negative trial um
could we zoom out just for a second and
give people an overview of
the objective or the hypothesis of the
stuff yeah the question that was being
tested was
is um an intermittent dose of pure
synthetic psilocybin
um more effective i think is the way the
question was posed
than the top-tier ssri
for uh patients with depression so
lexapro
is a relatively new ssri very well
tolerated
yeah um it does have sexual side effects
that's its most common side effect
that's true of other ssris absolutely
yeah ssris are known for having sexual
side effects
some of them also come with you know
incredible amounts of somnolence
incredible amounts of weight gains
sleeping sleepiness yeah um lexapro
seems to be relatively free of that for
most people which is why it's kind of
more of a
go-to drug it comes in two doses 10 and
20 milligrams
generally most people need 20 if they're
going to go to it but usually start
people at 10 go to 20.
this is a daily it's a daily drug yep
so you know the participants are divided
into two groups one group is given
um lexapro uh let me think i believe
that they all started out at 10
milligrams
for three weeks and then were increased
to 20 milligrams for three weeks or
maybe it was four plus four i can't
remember it's a relatively short study
in the psilocybin group the participants
were give oh they were by the way it's
in the side they were also given one
milligram of psilocybin
um which is an important point i should
make
and if that word is unfamiliar to folks
so psilocybin
is a molecule found in philosophy
mushrooms
also known as magic mushrooms these are
mushrooms that impart psychedelic
effects at a sufficient dose we'll come
to talk about that dose so the subjects
were all recruited
knowing that they would get psilocybin
no matter what
because that was an important recruiting
tool people wanted to be in a study
where they were going to get the
psilocybin and that's
that has to be taken into account from
the standpoint
of patient selection so every trial
has to be thoughtful about what type of
people it's selecting and are they
representative
of the population you're going to want
to extrapolate your results to
so i flagged this to make the point that
when
you have a patient population that says
i really really want to get psilocybin
and you say okay well you're not going
to get necessarily the full dose there's
only a 50 50 chance you're going to get
the full dose but you're going to get
some so you're going to get one
milligram
or 25 milligrams and we'll put in
context what those doses mean in a
second
just to bracket one thing so the the
what makes this
what makes this study and paper worthy
of discussion
is that it is a head-to-head comparison
with lots of nuance of course of
psilocybin with i think two or three
sessions
total in the intervention arm versus
uh lexapro very common ssri
for major depressive disorder yep please
continue
yeah so to your point um
the group that was in the true
psilocybin group
received i think it's just two doses
spaced out three weeks apart
of 25 milligrams of psilocybin
which um depending on the variant of
mushrooms so when you dry a mushroom out
its yield of psilocybin pure psilocybin
can be as low
i mean i went and reviewed all the lit
on this can be as low as 1.7 percent can
be as high by weight can be as high as
you know even four or five percent so
incredible variability yeah so the 25
milligrams
was clearly a hallucinogenic dose
so probably in the 4 to 5 gram of
mushroom
dose so they used a number of well
there's one other point i should explain
about research
um generally when research is done in a
credible fashion
you have to call your shot before you do
the study pointing to center field
that's right you have to be able to
not just say i'm going to hit a home run
i'm going to hit a home run over that
wall
and that's called your primary objective
so
one of the things that is important to
understand when you're evaluating
research
is was it pre-registered so when the
study
right did they call this shot by naming
their
and so in the united states uh
anything that's funded by nih for
example has to be pre-registered
on clinicaltrials.gov so i would
encourage anybody to go to
clinicaltrials.gov and just start
perusing and what you'll see there
is a list of all of these ongoing
studies they'll say you know it started
here
and it's a template so it always looks
the same and it's very easy to navigate
these things you know
here are the investigators here's the
hypothesis here's the experimental
design here's the inclusion criteria the
exclusion criteria
here the primary here is the primary
outcome here are the secondary outcomes
and it shows you all of that stuff so
you have to pre-register this you have
to state what you're doing
if you don't do that it becomes very
difficult to publish your work in
anything prestigious
this of course was published in the
hands down most prestigious medical
journal in the world in english journal
of medicine
so they pre-registered around one type
of survey
one type of depressive survey because
unlike
say giving people drug to treat
cholesterol where you have an objective
metric you can say well did it lower
apob or ldlc or something like that here
you're relying on
subjective outcomes because in such a
short study
you're clearly not going to be able to
follow people for
wait was there less depression in this
or was there less suicide in this group
or something you know like a hard
outcome you know
did people have you know fewer absent
days from work or something like that
so the uh and it's been a while since i
wrote this
the primary survey that they used i
believe had nine categories or maybe it
was 12
and the difference between the groups
the
lexapro group and the psilocybin group
was not statistically significant so
both groups achieved an improvement in
their depressive scores
i think it was six and four points
respectively
correct i think it's a nine point scale
something like that but you you pointed
out something very
important and i guess we should just
step back for a second so the the upshot
and then let's come back to these
questions but the the upshot
summary of the study was what
there was no difference between this
drug
and it basic between psilocybin and this
it was positioned as a negative study
got it meaning it i mean i don't want to
say failed because that's just not
really how science works but
it it that the intervention did not
meaning well psilocybin in this case was
not superior
to that that's right yeah yes telegram
thai that's right
uh all right so this this is
a topic that is endlessly interesting to
me
what we're getting into it's just steady
design
and really digging into the nuance and
how beneficial it is
to know how to read a study and
i mean this will seem like
uh maybe just a friendly plug but i
highly recommend people read a series of
articles that you published and they are
called what is it studying the studies
or studying studies studying studies
to increase your scientific literacy
because we're going to get into some of
the weeds and i think it'll be
i i hope it'll be interesting and the
other thing we're doing if i can plug
something and i don't know when we'll
have this
out yet but we're creating a course um
where
about a year ago we started recording
our weekly journal our monthly journal
club so every month inside our practice
we do journal club
um which is just like old school journal
club for anybody who's been in a lab
so one person will present a paper it
usually takes an hour to an hour and a
half
and we get into and a complete
dissection of the paper and we do it in
a really kind of methodical way
and the the topics vary greatly so
highly recommend
everyone do this honestly witnessing the
complete
mayhem and confusion over the last year
with respect to
anything science related uh certainly
the most obvious of which being anything
coveted or vaccine related has
has made it so clear to me that this is
really
i mean like it's hard for me to think of
something that is higher priority
if yeah and we just decided to do this i
mean
you know we've been doing journal club
inside our practice for years
but it occurred to me a year ago why
aren't we recording this
to later package and put out there
because
nobody is nobody comes out of the womb
knowing how to read science like we just
have to accept the fact that completely
learned
it is a totally non-innate thing
evolution had zero desire to teach us
this skill
so you have to learn it and you know
some of us were really lucky to be in
labs where people were really good
mentors
and they they beat into you how to do
this
and um and and again the topics that we
explore
are you know the latest on semi-glutide
which we'll talk about today i think uh
you know
the role of testosterone replacement
therapy in men with type 2 diabetes a
huge paper that came out recently
this topic so um it doesn't matter what
the subject matter is the
the process of thinking is actually
quite the process of of
thinking dissecting and skeptically but
not necessarily cynically
looking at the purported outcomes i
think is
is really important so coming back to
the coming back to this paper
super prestigious journal
study comes out psilocybin versus
lexapro
negative study or a negative outcome
rather
then we have this questionnaire let's
just call it
that is determining the results
and the results come back to the
differences come back as statistically
insignificant
however right as you pointed out when
you wrote about this
that doesn't necessarily mean clinically
insignificant
depending or does it mean that it wasn't
so let's go back and explain what
statistical significance is as well
because now there's three points you
reminded me of something else that i
think is worth stating
how is statistical significance
determined and what does it mean we hear
this term all the time
statistical significance is basically
asking a question what is the
probability
that the difference that's observed
between these groups is by chance
to answer that question you have to know
a priori
how big an effect size you would expect
to see between these two groups
a priori meaning beforehand you need to
know what magnitude of difference
you would expect to see between the two
groups that's right and that's really
important because that determines what's
called the power of your study
and that is how you need to sorry to
keep jumping in here but the
the part of the importance of
determining or speculating or guessing
correctly the magnitude of difference
like the difference in effect sizes
because that also will determine how
many
subjects you need to recruit right so
there's something called a power
table which i think we include in one of
the studying
studies um uh articles
which i remember when i got to the lab
was one of the first things my
pi principal investigator showed me he
said this is
going to be one of the most important
tables
you'll ever pay attention to when you're
doing research
because the table has on
it's a complicated table to look at but
on the like horizontal axis
it has effect size of treatment a
on the vertical axis it has difference
between treatment a and treatment b so
this will be like
10 15 20
and then here it would be like 5 10 15
20. so
for example treatment a would yield if
you predict it's going to be a 30
effect size versus a 40 effect size you
go to 30 and 10. does that make sense
the baseline plus the delta and then
within each square
you typically have two options at either
80 or 90
power obviously 90 power means an even
higher standard and it requires
more sample like it has a greater sample
size
so it's very common in research
to under estimate
or overestimate your effect size
and if you overestimate the effect size
you can underpower a study and i think
there's actually a pretty
sizable chance that that happened here
because the power analysis
suggested they were looking for a four
point difference on this scale it came
back with two
it came back with a little over two
little over two yeah
so it's not surprising that it came back
not statistically significant because
they had engineered the number of
participants to only be statistically
significant if there is a difference of
four points or greater
and so on the one hand you would say
well that's really impressive that was a
very high bar
my question is was it too high a bar is
four points necessary
when you're really trying to do a study
against
the gold standard right it would be one
thing if you were doing a study against
a placebo
where you do want to set a very very
high bar
but this is akin to almost like a phase
three drug
trial where you're trying to compare a
new drug
to an existing blockbuster gold standard
drug
and simply being non-inferior to it and
maybe even potentially better on some of
the secondary metrics as this one was
could be more than enough to advance
clinical utilization
and promulgate further studies so that
was
one of my first concerns with this study
i don't think it was powered correctly
because i i do wonder if
4 4 was too high in expectation
against this treatment of course other
issues are was this study long enough
right this was a relatively short study
um and it looked it could have gone the
other way it might be that after a year
it flipped and lexapro was hands down
the winner and psilocybin's effect waned
we don't know
um but but again that's another thing to
be concerned with and then the point
that you brought up
um is which is a subset of what we were
just talking about is look
maybe a two and a half point increase is
clinically really relevant and the other
point here is i definitely want you to
give uh if you remember and it can be
rough but yeah some of the some of these
have the questions that's right
and that's that's the final point here
is not all questions are created equal
right so some of the questions on that
scale
are like um you know
do you are there times when you don't
feel good about yourself
versus you know like there are days i
can't get out of bed
those are not the same question to me
like those are very different questions
a person who says
yeah like honestly more than 50 time i
don't feel good about myself clearly
that's a problem and clearly that's
something you want to address but that's
that person is probably a lot more
functional than the person who says
i can't get out of bed yeah or i think
that you know the
uh another two examples to compare would
be
one about suicidal thought as well right
right and or
i sleep ten or fewer hours per day
or 12 or more hours per day and that
might account for say a two-point
difference
on an individual questionnaire but then
another question which was something
like i
feel badly about myself most of the time
versus or on a daily basis versus uh
say less than half the time or something
along those lines yeah then as you
mentioned
questions about that that could include
suicidal ideation so not
all points are created equal right
uh you know another thing that um you
know i wondered because um
i have you know in part helped fund
research at imperial college uh where
this came out of
and a bunch of other places and in
conversations with
a number of different neuroscientists
they said well these are people are very
experienced
with uh designing studies and being
published they said well you know
there are times when you you have to
choose between
the primary outcome measure you think
the establishment so to speak is going
to most respect
or the primary outcome measure that you
think is going to move the most
and this could be a case and i'm not
speaking for
robin or anyone else involved with this
study but this could be an example of
picking what the establishment would
have wanted to see
and then having the the
secondary outcome measures move
uh in some some very interesting ways
that
uh maybe in retrospect could have or
should have been
the primary outcome measure correct if
you had more confidence in those to
begin with
uh so it's it's just do you know what
the budget was for this study
for this study i don't but i'm i'm glad
you mentioned
budget simply because i think this
underscores how important at least
in the u.s i'm involved with with
hopkins and
ucsf and a number of other places how
important it is
to try to open up uh state and federal
funding for this type of research from
nimh
nih et cetera because right now it's
easy for someone to say well that was
stupid why didn't they just have
50 people in each arm and the answer is
it costs a lot of [ __ ] money
and it's hard to raise money uh in in
some cases
i mean look i think net net this study
must be viewed as a very positive
finding
yeah because the side effect profile was
obviously higher in lexapro so again
people taking lexapro are far more
likely to complain of
um if they're males erectile dysfunction
sexual
malfunction reduced libido things like
that um
i you know how we wouldn't want to
explore this to the nth degree i don't
understand
and of course there's other things i'd
want to explore like microdosing right
these were macrodoses
so these are people taking you know a
full hallucinogenic dose
every two three weeks i believe um and
that's not necessarily an easy thing to
do either so we you know i'd want to
understand what that's like versus
what would taking a couple of milligrams
per day
which would be you know well below the
threshold of perception
or three times a week or something you
know you hear a lot of anecdotal talk
about those things being beneficial to
people i'd like to see that studied and
in some ways that would be an easier
thing to study
because that's the other limitation of
this study which
must be noted which is technically it
wasn't it was not a blinded study
yeah it was a randomized study but it
wasn't a blinded study there was no
confusion about which
group you were in it's uh this is one of
the biggest
challenges i think there are ways to
solve for it that i find pretty
compelling from a scientific standpoint
but
it's very hard to blind
when you're using hallucinogenic a much
less
sort of mystical experience level dosing
of
a psychedelic and it raises uh
you know as you noted given the
frequency of administration so you have
say two sessions with psilocybin
at clearly psychedelic doses these would
be
uh i i would say in most people
sufficient
to produce uh some
type of what you might call mystical
experience and there are questionnaires
that johns hopkins
uh has developed uh roland griffiths and
matt johnson
and and that team to measure
mystical experience ego dissolution
sense of unity etc
but when you let when you look at the
results and
we assume for the time being even though
i think people should look really
closely at the appendices and the
secondary outcome measures
let's say that their breakeven all right
this is a tie but on one hand
as you said you have more side effects
you have daily administration and then
on the other hand
you have administration every three
weeks
and i i think that were they too
and they may still plan on doing
follow-ups of the
in in in other university studies
there's quite a bit of durability that's
seen
with this type of administration of soul
side even out to six 12 months
it raises some really interesting
questions right
the most obvious of which is how does
this work
because if the ssris are on some level
i don't want to say suppressing symptoms
maybe masking tendencies i don't know
the right way to phrase it but
it is a maintenance drug it's an
ongoing administration versus highly
intermittent
by what mechanism are these changes
taking place right is it
is it just flooding the brain with a
compound that has a biochemical effect
or
does it relate more to changing the
content and narrative and sort of
what work can be done in those sessions
themselves
raises a lot of interesting questions
yeah and i think
with mdma i think the answer is probably
a bit more clear
i think when you prior to mdma's
resurgence and and you know serious
treatment for ptsd
antidepressants were the mainstay of
therapy for this and
i think it was exactly what you said i
mean uh antidepressants for ptsd were a
masking
agent um that had some efficacy but not
tremendous efficacy i think the runaway
success we're seeing of mdma for ptsd
is clearly less about
the chemical changes in the brain as a
result of the administration of the
molecule and far
more about the state of mind that it
puts the individual in
for the type of therapy that they need
to do to go back
and rectify and come to grips with the
traumatic event
and i think you're right i think it's
less clear here but
it also doesn't have to be one or the
other it's it's certainly possible it
could be both
and there's been for those people
interested in reading more and i can
link to these in the show notes
uh for this episode there has been some
great new york times coverage
of uh the phase three trials related to
mdma assisted psychotherapy uh includes
stories from subjects uh and
it's it's a very compelling read the
results are really pretty staggering
and raised a lot of a lot of exciting
questions
for me just about the future of
treating mental illness or psychiatric
disorders
and i also want to give just a
shout out to rick perry in texas who has
been
recently very public about
exploring psychedelic compounds as
possible treatments for things like ptsd
among veteran populations
and other subpopulations so that
that i think is a very it's very
courageous and very justifiable
stance to take so i was very excited to
see that especially in the
great republic of texas in which we sit
that's right
uh any other any other studies uh that
that come to mind or you mentioned apo b
i'm wondering if you have any thoughts
on apob that you'd like to share yeah
certainly as it pertains to things where
i'm
evolving my thinking i'm and what is
apob yeah it's probably worth explaining
that before we do anything else so
most people have heard of cholesterol um
and most people are used to seeing a
blood test where you would see your
total cholesterol
ldl hdl and if if the lab is half decent
it would actually say ldl dash
c hdl dash c non hdl-cv
what does all that mean so that means
ldl cholesterol or the cholesterol
contained within ldl
hdl cholesterol is the cholesterol
contained within ldl so why do all these
things even exist so every cell in our
body makes cholesterol
um it's an essential molecule for life
so if you don't have cholesterol you're
not going to live
more than you know a few seconds in fact
you'll die in utero if we're going to be
blunt
so every cell makes this thing
it's it makes up the cell membrane of
every cell
it's what allows membranes to have
fluidity and have transporters sitting
across them
it's also the backbone for many of the
hormones we make
now the problem is cholesterol is not
water soluble
so when you have something that's not
water-soluble that needs to be
transported through the body which this
does
because as i said not every cell makes
enough of it to meet their own needs
so there are net exporters and net
importers of cholesterol
you have to have a system that can move
it around
but just like if you tried to pour olive
oil into a glass of water you would
quickly realize they don't mix
and similarly you can't just move
cholesterol through the bloodstream
the way you can move things like glucose
sodium potassium
things that are water soluble so glucose
just travels to the bloodstream on its
own
as does a ketone body for example but
triglycerides you know have to be bound
things that are fat soluble have to be
bound so
you know mother nature invented
something called a lipoprotein which is
a
spherical thing that on the outside
is water soluble and on the inside
houses these water insoluble or what we
call hydrophobic
things namely cholesterol ester and
triglycerides and these lipoproteins
exist
in two broad families and the families
are defined
by the protein signature that wraps
around them
so the two families are the apo b family
and the apo a family technically there's
a
sub class of the apo b's there's an apo
b 100
and an apo b 48 but for the most part
anybody
that's talking about apo b is referring
to apob 100 the apo
b48 is only something called a kyla
micron
that is a very short-lived lipoprotein
that gets fat out of your gut
so let's put that guy aside for the
moment unless anyone wants to come back
and we'll do the advanced course on the
weekend
okay advanced course for the
midichlorians your nerds out there all
right
didn't you so your your apo b family
consists of very low density lipoprotein
or vldl intermediate density lipoprotein
or idl
low density lipoprotein or ldl and
lp little a who is the worst actor of
the bunch which is an
ldl with another special lipoprotein
wrapped around him
called an apoa or an apolipoprotein
little a
not apoa i should be really clear it's
apolipoprotein little a you have to
specify little a to not confuse it with
the apoa family the apoa family
is the lineage of the high density
lipoproteins
okay most people know that hdl
good ldl bad but that's a little overly
simplistic what we really mean to say
is that hdls do not cause
atherosclerosis
ldls do but it turns out ldls aren't the
only thing that cause atherosclerosis
anything with an apob on it causes
atherosclerosis and
just just to just for the for the
listeners
atherosclerosis meaning the buildup of
plaque
within the cardiovascular system yeah i
think it's the it's the
difference it's the inflammatory disease
of arteries
that ultimately results in plaque
formation
and in the worst case scenario results
in rupture of this plaque that leads to
an acute thrombosis or an acute
occlusion
and if it occurs in the wrong spot that
can be fatal
instantly fatal got it so vldls
stick around for long enough that if you
have too many of them they are
atherogenic
idls are not really a problem because
they just don't last that long so the
transit from vldl to idl
and then ideal to hdl occurs to ldl is
so quick that the idls are kind of
irrelevant
ldls of course are the majority of your
apo b concentration
unless you also have a lot of insulin
resistance where you might have a lot of
vldls or if you have a genetic condition
that predisposes you to have too many of
those the ideals again we don't really
worry about those
the ldls are the lion's share of your
apob and
about one in eight to one in 12 people
also have a very genetically high level
of lp little a
and that also represents um part of the
apob concentration so
apob is a far superior measurement to
ldlc when trying to predict
cardiovascular risk
so it is hands down the best biomarker
we have for cardiovascular risk
because it is the total concentration of
all particles
capable of inducing atherosclerosis now
atherosclerosis is multifactorial so
lots of things drive it inflammation
plays an important role and metabolic
health plays a super important role
but we understand that lower apob
is better where i think that the data
are becoming more and more clear
is how low you can push this thing
without unwanted effects
and how much more benefits you can get
so there's always a concern i think
and understandably so that if you lower
apob
you're lowering cholesterol because if
you have fewer of the particles that
carry cholesterol
you have less cholesterol floating
around the blood but what most people
don't understand
is that that's sort of like saying i'm
going to reduce the number of
cars traveling over this bridge
does that necessarily mean you're
reducing the number of cars in the city
not necessarily so most of the
cholesterol
in your body is not in the lipoproteins
rummaging around
through your veins
again most of the cholesterol is still
sitting inherently
in the cells itself so if you took a
person's total cholesterol
and it was 200 milligrams per deciliter
and you lowered it
and up by total cholesterol by the way
at this point i assume is
straightforward
to explain it's the sum of all the
cholesterol and all the lipoproteins so
the
vldl idl ldl lp little a and hdl if you
bash all of those particles and take out
all the cholesterol that's what your
total cholesterol is
if you took that number from 200 to 100
you would say god that's a 50
reduction in your cholesterol no it's a
reduction in your serum cholesterol
which might be like
a 5 to 10 reduction in your total body
cholesterol
so that's one thing to keep in mind the
other thing to keep in mind is
we are born with very very low levels of
cholesterol
so in a child the apob concentration
is probably in the ballpark of 30 20 to
30 milligrams per deciliter
by the time we're adults a level of 80
milligrams per deciliter
would put you at the 20th percentile
meaning 80
of people would have a higher number
than 80.
what's the upshot of this the upshot of
this is there's no upside to having more
apob
right the the upside is in having that
number be
lower and lower and lower but until
recently it wasn't clear how low you
could drive it and there was a
a type of drug that was developed about
well i mean developed about 17 18 years
ago but it be
it became clinically available i
shouldn't say that actually it's
probably started development in about 05
so it's called 16 years ago hit the
market in 2014 or 2015 a class of drug
called pcsk9 inhibitors
and they work in a manner that's
distinct from all previous drugs that
lower
cholesterol they work by inhibiting a
protein
that degrades ldl receptors on the liver
and by inhibiting this thing that
degrades them you
get more of the ldl receptors on the
liver it pulls more of the ldl receptor
it pulls more of the apob bearing
particles out of circulation
mostly which are ldl particles but also
some lp little a particles
with these trials we see people
achieving
levels of apob in the 10 to 30 range
with no side effects no consequences
furthermore these drugs were developed
when populations of people were
identified who naturally had mutations
in pcsk9 that rendered their pcsk9
ineffective
so this was basically a drug that was
designed to mimic
a genetic mutation found in people who
over the course of their lives have no
increased risk of any disease and simply
have a decrease in their risk of
cardiovascular disease in fact the risk
of cardiovascular disease is virtually
non-existent
yes because silly question how does how
does one find
people who have such a mutation to track
them
well it started with the opposite so
there's a condition called
familial hypercholesterolemia or fh for
short
which are people who have very high
levels of cholesterol and very high
levels of ldl cholesterol
and by extension very high levels of
apob and they're pretty
easy to spot um but
it's a definition that is based on
phenotype not genotype so it's genetic
condition
but it's one phenotype but
3 000 or more genotypes meaning there
are
thousands of different genetic mutations
that lead to that
i think it was in the late 90s one of
those genetic pathways was identified
as a hyper-functioning pcsk9
so a group in toronto identified pcsk9
and realized that these people had a
hyper functioning version of this
protein
and it was constantly degrading ldl
receptors
and so they just couldn't clear the apob
out of their circulation and that's why
they had sky-high ldl
and total cholesterol when that
population was identified the question
was asked which is is there a
counterpart to them
and it turns out to be really easy to
identify them because they're the
opposite these are people who don't take
any medicine to lower their cholesterol
and they have levels like infants
and then it was realized and i remember
actually reading that paper when it came
out and being blown away
and actually thinking there's no way
they're going to be able to do this with
a drug
um but it turned out it was it was
actually pretty druggable
it wasn't that hard to do and in many
ways it's a much
cleaner drug than say a statin like
statins which are
despite all the public mayhem around it
and the religious polarizing debates
around staten statins are really safe
drugs
10 of people have unwanted side effects
and shouldn't take them
um but they're very well tolerated drugs
and in my mind that's kind of a miracle
when you consider what they do
which is they inhibit cholesterol
synthesis and when you think about how
important cholesterol synthesis is
it's kind of amazing to me that that
works without killing people
my hypothesis for this by the way is
that statins occurred in nature
so the first statins were really
copying something that was found in
nature called red yeast rice
and as a general rule i think things
that came from nature
tend to be a little safer you know
psilocybin
um rapamycin metformin some of my other
favorite drugs
um but this the method of by which the
pcsk9 works
is is just elegant because it's really
just targeting one protein
with a you know with an antibody that
makes it
um harder for the ldl receptor to break
down
are there any benefits to lowered
or low apob
uh outside of cardiac risk lowering
cardiac risk yeah there actually is
i shouldn't say cardio cardiovascular
risk yeah yeah yeah and
and that's sort of um i mean i think
we've known
for for a while that it also poses a
benefit with respect to alzheimer's
disease
for sure um and
that's one of those things where i think
one needs to be a little bit careful
about never confusing population data
with individual data and it's why i
think population data are
fantastic but every patient has to be
completely assessed as an individual
so the population based data for as long
as we've had statins we've known
that lower apob or lower ldlc means less
risk of alzheimer's disease
and if you think about some of the paths
by which people get alzheimer's disease
there's clearly a vascular path so
alzheimer's disease is not a disease
in in just in the same way cancer is not
a disease
singular it's many diseases not just
tissue type but even within tissue type
you know within breast cancer
for example you have different receptor
profiles the same within lung cancer
so or even just the mutation can render
two cancers completely different animals
and similarly alzheimer's disease is a
collection of lots of diseases with a
final common pathway
but you can get there metabolically you
can get there
through a vascular path you can get
there through an inflammatory path
there might even be an autoimmune path
there the vascular path is a big path in
my opinion
and therefore anything that improves
microvascular health which statins do
should improve um uh the risk of
alzheimer's disease so
there was something called the mendelian
randomization that was published
i think like literally a week ago and
i'll explain what a mendelian
randomization
yeah mendel yeah yeah um so i guess i
should explain what it would
what an mr is first mr is um
mendelian randomization correct is
a very elegant tool that allows us
to try to infer cause when an experiment
is not done
this is a profound idea right because
when you just
observe things without doing an
experiment which by definition
means randomly assigning treatments
or assigning treatments to randomly
separated groups which is the only way
to
eliminate all bias there are other
biases that can creep in
which we could i mean which are actually
discussed in the study and studying
section i won't go into like performance
bias and other things like that
but for much of
the questions we're interested in you
can't do that you have to rely on
natural experiments
so what mr allows you to do
is identify genes
that are responsible for the traits at
hand
and not responsible for other traits and
do basically a model of what does that
genetic trait tell you when it's present
or not resin so the
the idea is in an mr analysis
you're basically assuming that genes can
occur randomly which of course they can
and you're then looking at what is the
outcome from that so for example in the
case of apob
you would look at genes that are
determining apob level and there are
many
genes that play an important role in
understanding
how high or low a person's apo b is and
these genes are set
right it's sort of like you get the gene
you get you know you're not going to
change the gene
and it's not subject to your behavior
right whereas so many other things like
what you eat
is a behavior that can also impact your
apo b so it it's it's how do you strip
that effect out the healthy user bias
all of the things that are are
problematic when trying to infer this
and the mr demonstrated quite clearly
that
lower apob is synonymous with improved
all-cause mortality cardiovascular
mortality and even mortality associated
with diabetes and things like
that to me the most interesting finding
in there was the all-cause mortality
i you know on the one level you could
say well it's not surprising given that
cardiovascular mortality is the greatest
cause of mortality in the developed
world so if you take a big enough chunk
out of that you should
improve all cause mortality but
nevertheless that
trial or not that trial that study
combined with
a number of other um very large
cardiovascular trials
namely fourier odyssey improve it
every truck every trial has to have a
cool name um
just demonstrate this effect where lower
is better the lower the ldl goes where
the apob
goes the lower the risk goes let's jump
to rapamycin
since you mentioned it and uh we can
give a very quick
idea on what rivomycin is but since we
last spoke
uh more bearish more bullish and why
um i am i'm a bull
yeah dogecoin and rapper
diamond hands all right so what is rap
by the way
i mean i know i know what the diamond
hands thing is but what is it where did
it come from like
no idea yeah no idea where diamond hands
comes from
okay i i was like did i miss that
somewhere in my in my
in your in your econ classes yeah yeah
yeah
no i don't think so okay so what is
rapamycin
so rapamycin is a drug that
um is a naturally occurring uh
anti-fungal agent made by a bacteria
that was discovered on easter island
back in the 1960s otherwise known as
rapa nui
right rapa nui is the correct name for
easter island and the bacteria
streptomyces hydroscopicus which was
discovered there
by a group of explorers explorers is
maybe the wrong word but people doing
sort of medical prospecting
uh a group from montreal i believe in
they took a bunch of soil and dirt back
from
rapa nui to the lab in montreal where it
sort of sat there
unattended to for about five years uh a
chemist a very astute chemist by the
name of siren seagal
right now yeah he related to steven
seagal
no different uh and no ponytail
fortunately
um so siren did some really interesting
chemistry
isolated the compound and noticed it had
these really remarkable properties
which was it was the most potent
anti-fungal agent
he had ever seen or the world had ever
seen frankly
at the time as his son ajit tells the
story
who i've gotten to know a little bit he
felt he had basically come on to the
biggest block duster blockbuster
cure for athlete's foot the world was
ever going to know and right about that
time the company he worked for
closed its montreal headquarters
actually laid many people off
ordered the destruction of all
non-viable compounds and shipped him off
to new jersey
in one of the greatest acts of
scientific fortuity he did not
follow orders and he instead stuck
said rapamycin into a little mini
freezer
that he and his family transported to
their new home in new jersey they kept
it in the
freezer for many years until ultimately
another drug company purchased the
company he worked for
and the new management said hey anybody
working on anything interesting he said
i'm working on this thing interesting
that i haven't looked at in a few years
and they said
bring it out must have been an
interesting uh lawyer conversation
based on the not following orders
continue yeah so
out came uh rapamycin which he named uh
mycen and you know mycen is typically
the uh the prefix the suffix i guess
that we use or what's the what's the
second part of a word called
for for antimicrobial agents and of
course rapa as a tribute to the rapa nui
like azithromycin correct yep so
it it quickly became clear that this had
remarkable
anti-proliferative properties so it
could stop
things from proliferating so that was
obviously a big of just fungi
right exactly and in particular um
it was very effective at making a
certain type of lymphocyte
which is a white type of white blood
cell not proliferate
and it then basically went down the path
eventually
pfizer then bought amorous which was the
company that bought his previous company
whose name i don't even remember at this
point
um pfizer ended up pursuing this and it
was fda approved in 1999
for treatment of organ transplantation
so patients that have an organ
transplanted
have to be put on a really heavy regimen
of drugs to suppress
a part of their immune system called the
cellular immune system
that will attack a foreign organ that's
what is that called host graft
no no graft versus host is actually when
the
organ usually it's in the case of
lymphoma or leukemia when someone has a
bone marrow transplant
and the the graft what they've been
transplanted attacks the host
i see it yeah yeah this is this is
really host versus graft but we don't
usually talk about that yeah but
traditional sort of
you know rejection actually i did a
really cool podcast on the topic of
organ transplantation history with a guy
named chris sanenday
and it's i mean i know this subject well
but having a discussion with chris
really opened my eyes to just what a
beautiful story it is
and what the big breakthroughs were with
drug development
and how you know at one point it was
like all you could give people was
prednisone and
you couldn't save anybody and then you
know you had
other drugs like cyclosporine that were
introduced but then you get into this
third generation of amazing drugs like
rapamycin that took organ
uh you know preservation to uh to a
higher level
now you're not swapping kidneys
how do you know well at least not since
the last time you sold one
tijuana settled a bad but
why would you take grapomycin i know i'm
skipping ahead a little bit well let's
see yeah so let's skip ahead so
so 99 this drug comes on the market for
um for for organ rejection
and about 12 years later
a study gets published by rich miller
randy strong and colleagues
as part of what's called the
interventions testing program or the itp
which is an amazing nih-funded program
that tests molecules that
are believed to have a shot at enhancing
longevity and it does so in a
really really rigorous way probably the
most rigorous way we can test small
animals
um i've interviewed rich miller as well
probably one of my five favorite
podcasts in terms of like nerding out on
all of the molecules that can
potentially impact longevity
and rapamycin was in many ways the
poster child for the itp program
because um first of all it's hard to get
anything to live longer
second of all when they were making the
formulation for the rapamycin to feed
the mice and these were very
special mice these were not your typical
crappy lab mice that have no bearing
whatsoever to real animals these are a
very special type
of mice that are much more akin to real
animals and that's a very
important distinction between what
happens in 99
of mouse research which is almost
inapplicable to humans and it's why
so many drugs that get tested in these
you know b6 mice and things like that
you know show some marker of success and
they become wild failures
beyond the mice but this was different
they had trouble getting the formulation
to work
and by the time they finally did the
mice were like
20 months old which means they're almost
at the end of their life
they're like 70 year old 65 year old
mice
and they contemplated just scrapping the
experiment but they were like ah screw
it let's just
run it late so they started feeding the
treatment group with rapamycin and the
placebo group get to continue eating
their regular chow
i guess it was oral administration yes
it was the rapamycin was mixed into
their chow
and lo and behold the rapamycin group
despite initiating treatment so late in
life
had a staggering improvement in lifespan
there's been so many itps that have
replicated this i don't want to misquote
it but something to the effect of like a
17 or 19 percent improvement in the
males
or in the females and 11 to 12 percent
in the males
and remember the itp uses a very
rigorous way of assessing this which is
they're taking a look at the remaining
life
or sorry they're taking a look at total
life not just remaining life
so it's a it's it's an even higher bar
to clear what
how much lifespan elongation happens
they of course immediately went and
repeated the study
administering the dose when they were
younger and saw an even greater response
this has been repeated over and over and
over again
and to my knowledge there was not a
single animal study
that has tested this hypothesis that has
not found
this result oh that's wild which again
is
very unusual yeah so it's just
replicated
over and over and over it's replicated
non-stop uh what is also
interesting is when looking at other
markers
other interesting things such as vision
and hearing and other markers of health
span we continue to see
improvements in these things for animals
as well and as i think we even spoke
about before
a guy named matt caberline who i'm just
interviewed for a second time for the
podcast
has been studying this in companion dogs
and looking
at heart function because as you know
basically two things kill companion
dogs primarily heart failure and cancer
and so the question is what would you be
able to do
to mitigate um especially heart failure
congestive heart failure in dogs
especially large dogs which are more
susceptible to this
and again the the the results though the
research is limited because there's not
an enormous
interest in funding this research and
it's expensive to fund research
in dogs that live so long um it's all
pointing in the same direction
so when you contrast metformin
and rapamycin you have the opposite
thing right in metformin we have tons of
human data that are not randomized
but are suggesting in cohorts that
metformin is also
protective but in a subset of people
that have diabetes so it's not as clear
how protective metformin will be in
in people that do not in the itp
metformin did not succeed
in other words metformin did not extend
uh life
in the mice when given alone when it was
given with rapamycin it did but you
could argue that was all the rapamycin
um i'm more bullish on rappa simply
because i'm
you know i've been taking it now for
three years
outside of you can hear dog whistles
um outside of um you know the aphthous
ulcers which are the most annoying side
effect of them
those are those little mouth little
mouth sores you get a canker sore
which you don't get i don't get them de
novo but if i like if one of my kids
headbutts me which
they do at an alarming frequency um
and my if i break a piece of my gum like
it's going to be an aptus ulcer
um although what is it called again
apathos ulcer apathy
yeah a p h t
h o s
yeah yeah nasty nasty doesn't sound fun
so that's the only is that the only
documented
in healthy normals i don't know who has
would fund this research if anyone would
um or i don't know what i guess i don't
even know what the measurements the
metrics would be but well that gets to
the problem
we don't have a meaningful biomarker of
aging
yeah i mean that's full stop the biggest
problem in aging research today
hands down nothing else matters yeah
when you don't have
a really good biomarker for aging
we're sort of sitting around twiddling
our thumbs
pontificating doing studies that look at
things that aren't that interesting
or things that are interesting but are
like
you know first order second order you
know but we just we can't see the whole
polynomial right like if you think back
to like what a taylor series is in
calculus if you're
trying to use a polynomial to estimate
sine x the first order term is
x equals y like that's interesting for
about that much but
you know when you really want to know x
minus x cubed over 3 factorial plus x to
the five over five factorial like when
you wanna really start figuring out the
shape of this thing you've gotta
you're just gonna need better tools so
as we're
talking about rapamycin i think
naturally a lot of people listening will
think of
life span it's a term they're more
familiar with right yep
start to finish what's what are you
clocking in in terms of years
and then there's health span and you
know i took a note as i always take
notes during these conversations about
the vision and the hearing
so i'm 43 and
recently had a not not quite an
audiology test i mean it wasn't
it was it was quite basic hearing test
done
and seemed to have some minor
hearing loss in the higher ranges
on one side could have been some of the
ambient noise in the room i don't know
i'd like to try to replicate it
but could one make a compelling
argument that rapamycin could improve
restoring that type of hearing or is
that too much of a stretch no
it's just too soon to say i i think it's
certainly plausible
but i think it's it's too early to say i
mean we've seen that we've seen that in
animals now we've seen we've seen that
in animals but
i don't know if that's going to
translate to humans has that been seen
in multiple species
i've only seen it in mice in mice yeah
but these are the
these are kind of the feral mice versus
the like holstein cows of mice
um to be honest with you i don't
remember what mice were used in that
study
um but it's quite possible they were
your garden variety
genetically not so interesting mice got
it you know you've
you've hinted at or outright identified
a big challenge which is
how do you study a drug in healthy
people and by the way a drug that has a
little bit of a bad rap
right immune suppressing drugs don't
have people very excited
and until 2014 until christmas day 2014
or christmas eve day
i didn't think of this as very
interesting so in 2011 you have the
first itp
published and it's like wow that's cool
but
i used to give this to kidney transplant
patients i'm not taking that
and then you had uh joan manick was the
lead author on a study that came out
at the end of 2014 that looked at a
rapamycin derivative called
everolimus and it was given
to um 65 year olds in the following
fashion there were four groups a group
that was given a placebo
a group that was given one milligram
every day a group that was given five
milligrams once a week and a group that
was given 20 milligrams once a week
and they were given this for a period of
eight weeks i believe
and then they were taken off everything
for another period of i believe six
weeks and then they were challenged with
a flu vaccine
and then looked to see who mounted the
best immune response
and you know counter to what you would
expect
the people in rapamycin developed a
better immune response
which flew entirely in the face of what
one
would have expected um the group getting
five milligrams once a week was in the
best they had the best response and the
fewest side effects so the 20
um we probably don't want to go down
this path because it's just more
complicated
there are two complexes of mtor there's
this we talk we got to talk about mtor
how does rapamycin work right it works
by inhibiting um something called mtor
the mechanistic target of rapamycin we
could also refer people to our
conversation with david sabatini
absolutely back on easter island back on
easter island so
long story short there was a trip it may
or may not have involved some wine
to rapa nui to easter island and
one of uh one of our
tripmates was david sabatini who
q heater was the first person to
identify
how rapamycin worked in mammals yeah so
we we talked about that quite a bit in
that episode so i think
if you just search tim ferriss show
easter island i can't imagine there are
many results
and you will see an amazing crow arm
displayed by another one of our trip
mates
which happens to just be an artifact
from a weird panoramic shot but we did
use that photo
just to just to shape his nuts a bit uh
so let's see yeah so let's just wrap
that up by saying that the five
milligram dose seemed to be the sweet
spot once a week it produced all the
benefit without the side effects 20
produced a similar benefit but had too
many side effects
do you no longer take metformin i do not
interesting what were some of i know you
referred to what was his last name
miller
oh rich miller rich miller what are some
of the other candidates
that are most interesting to you in
terms of pharmacological interventions
that that might extend lifespan or
health span
there are several others that were found
to have a significant lifespan
enhancement uh repeatedly one is a
carbos
um which is uh a favorite of our mutual
friend kevin rose
uh a carbos was introduced
by um so the way the itps work is really
cool
anybody can suggest a compound so it's
it's basically like uh
you know it's like a crowdsourcing thing
where you can decide like i want to know
if this molecule has a benefit and as
long as you can write the proposal which
contains the rationale for why
if they buy it like they're going to
study it so a carbos was suggested
because the idea is a carbos prevents
the absorption of starch
so if you eat a pizza you can you know
have half of it leave your body
basically without being absorbed
so still no footnote for kevin
i think the ratio of donuts and beer to
acarbose does matter probably at some
point oh sure yeah
yeah and you can only take so much a
carbos i mean it is a little hard on
your gut yeah because it's in the gut
that it's preventing the absorption
um and the thinking was well a carbos if
it's eliminating
a reasonable fraction of your glucose is
going to be a caloric restriction
mimetic or a crm
as they call them so let's see if that
works and it turned out a carbos did
work
but interestingly the animals hadn't the
animals who lived longer weren't any
lighter
and didn't have any lower levels of
average glucose
than their shorter lived counterparts so
whatever a carbos was doing to extend
life it wasn't
through making you eat less or making
you weigh
less or making you even have a lower
hemoglobin a1c
it almost assuredly worked by the only
other thing it did which was
lower the speed the spikes and peaks of
glucose it blunted those
so it spreads out the speed with which
glucose is hitting you
but lowers the spikes are you more
bullish on a carbos
than metformin no i don't think so i
would still probably
put metformin as a more interesting
agent i mean a carbos first of all is
just not an easy agent to take
yeah i mean unless you like diarrhea um
and maybe
maybe giardia is also a caloric
restriction medic
so um and honestly monthly dose of
typhoid fever
yeah yeah exactly right uh i'm always
one i'm just one giant about away from
goal weight
um i'm still more more optimistic about
metformin
but also metformin is more of a mystery
in fact our mutual friend
our other mutual friend from easter
island nav chandelle
this is one of the things that he works
on mr crow arms yeah
and um i'll be having nav back on the
podcast probably in early 22.
that was fantastic when when there's
some killer work that he's doing on the
mechanisms of metformin
and we'll we'll dive back into that um
but there is another drug that i think
is
super exciting that was recently
published in the itp
called canagaflozen kanaga flows
kennega flows in spelt actually as it
sounds with a c
and it is a class of drug known as an s
g l t ii inhibitor
rolls up the tongue yeah the sglt2i
and it works in the kidney
it's a more elegant version of a carbos
working in the kidney
so the kidney is kind of a cute organ
cute in that it's really smart
right i think evolution figured out that
it would be
too difficult to know all the things
that are bad for you
but it's really easy to know all the
things that are good for you
so the way the kidney works is it gets
obviously a
staggering amount of your circulation
like 25 of your cardiac output is
passing through your kidneys with every
time your heart pumps
and the first pass of the kidney is to
take everything in your blood and dump
it out
so it's sort of like saying i'm going to
clean my drawers
by throwing everything on the floor and
then only putting back in my drawers the
things that i want
and because again it's easier to know
you need glucose you need potassium you
need magnesium you need sodium
as opposed to this toxin might that
might
appear a hundred years from now or a
million years from now
so in the reabsorption process
canagaflozin blocks the reuptake of
glucose
so you end up peeing out a lot of
so this drug obviously was introduced to
treat people with type 2 diabetes
and it showed remarkable efficacy in
doing that so in
a healthy subject you would
be presenting the sort of traditional
old-fashioned symptoms of diabetes yeah
although not
quite to the same extent because it's
sort of gradient driven
so in the traditional osler sense where
you know literally diagnosis of diabetes
was made by tasting the urine and seeing
how sweet it was
those were patients that were presenting
with you know wildly uncontrolled
diabetes with a glucose of like 800
milligrams per deciliter you know
they're about to have a coma
i first learned what diabetes was when i
was in japan as an exchange student
and it's
sugar urine disease and it's really
obvious in the characters i had no idea
what did diabetes
you know i heard it on the oatmeal
commercial it's interesting because i
i'm guessing nobody in japan
actually has diabetes yeah today
yeah today when you have people eating
like rice with mayonnaise
yeah slightly more when you were there
yeah there's probably just like five
people with diabetes yeah
very few um so canegaflozin
mimics um or basically blunts this
reabsorption of glucose
uh very successful drug for the
treatment of diabetes and also
um in people with diabetes
is showing better effects when it comes
to heart failure
um better effects when it comes to
mortality
this is really in my opinion a
first-line drug for any patient with
diabetes
and it does not cause hypoglycemia
so if a normal person takes it they're
not going to have a
you know a dangerous drop in blood sugar
so it is also
blunting the spikes but it also seems to
lower the average as well
so kanaga flows in extended the lives of
mice in the itp
uh and and i don't remember the exact
numbers it wasn't quite as
diabetic or no no no no these are
perfectly normal
mice it wasn't as big an effect as
rapamycin but it was
bigger than most other things there
haven't been that many successes in the
itp
obviously most drugs fail the but the
successes like rapamycin
uh 17 uh alpha estradiol
cannagaflows in a carbos those are
you know some of the big successes and
of course they get tested over and over
again to make sure that they weren't
wondering it was the 17
something or other you just made 17
alpha estradiol was a very interesting
molecule
alpha estradiol which is not the
estrogen it's not normal estrogen which
is beta estradiol
and 17 alpha estradiol only improved
lifespan of
male mice it had no impact on female
mice
the thinking being that it somewhat
mimicked the estrogen protection
benefits
in a male but not in a female because
they already had estrogen
yeah that's super interesting yeah and
that's not a that's not a molecule that
to my knowledge is even
in clinical trials like i don't even
know if there's an ind for that molecule
that it's even i don't know what pharma
is doing with that information
how did that get submitted
for the itp yeah it's funny i asked rich
about that i'm just
backyard chemist who's like yeah it was
it was i inherited a bunch of oil money
here
i want you to make this no it was
effectively someone who had been
studying this molecule and thought like
i wonder if this would be interesting
for the hypothesized mechanism that it
would
offer some of the protective benefits of
estrogen without the without the
without the feminizing effects right so
it's it's
it doesn't have the sexual
characteristics of estrogen so the
question is
you know because if you gave a male a
whole bunch of estrogen you're not going
to make them live longer
yeah um because whatever benefits come
from it are going to be offset by about
a bunch of negatives
so just to scratch my own in curiosity
here so
can someone with enough money just push
whatever they want
through the itp to get something tested
or like what combination of factors
leads someone
to be able to take a candidate or
something they think is promising like a
17 alpha
let's talk about money i think honestly
it's just about having the time like
there's a candidate drug that i'd like
to put on and i just
haven't had the time to write a proposal
uh so maybe in a in a couple years i'll
when i finish the book and a few other
projects yeah i i there is a there is a
candidate that i think would be
interesting
and uh so so no it's just having a good
scientific case for it
yeah that's fascinating huh
should we do some stupidity i think
absurd things
anything particularly ridiculous that
you're doing these days or enjoying
i mean there's so many um i think with
the lockdown with the whole covid thing
i've never spent more time at home and
it's been amazing like it's been a huge
dream come true oh it's just
like take the most antisocial person in
the world and allow him to never have to
go out
um and that's been i think really great
for my family on some levels but also
it's mean that they've
it meant they've had to put up with more
of my stupid jokes and the
like just the dumb things that i think
about um
and so one of the things that i have
been really harping on and just drives
my wife nuts
is um you know when you eat a banana at
the very bottom there's that little
nubbin
yes you know the little part so i am
convinced that the nubbin
is like lethal like if you eat a nub and
you're going to die
and so all i do i'm the nub and police
of our house
because a lot of times you know how you
can never finish bananas like you
you buy them you buy like 10 and you
might eat three but then seven are gonna
go bad
yeah so we peel the bad ones and put
them in the
freezer to make smoothies later on
because we always add you know
frozen fruit to like make my protein
shakes or whatever
and when i do it i'm really careful to
never put the nubbin in like i peel it
but i keep the nub in in the peel and it
goes in the trash
but when my wife does it she just
so i'm like of course i don't care but i
act like i care and i'm like babe
are you serious like kind of nubbin in
here like there's people in the house
they could eat this like do you
understand like the nubbin is
like literally the third leading cause
of death worldwide
not in the developed world here it's
like the fifth leading cause of death
but when you average it out across the
globe third leading cause of death
nabitus so and it just doesn't get older
i think the more it bugs her the funnier
it is to me
and the same with my daughter like just
endless eye rolls
and they don't buy it they really think
they claim that you can eat a nub in and
nothing will happen to you depends on
your topo chico
too nubbin ratio in the house i think
you're pretty heavily weighted in the
former
all right what else any of the three
categories really if if there's
something i don't know
something else i've changed my mind on
yeah i'm way
way way more bullish on sauna than i
have ever been before
i used to be in the camp of sauna feels
great
it maybe even helps you sleep a bit
better
um that's probably about it like there's
no way you're going to really live
longer
because you're in asana and while
truthfully we don't have really great
prospective data
uh or sorry i should say we have good
prospective data we don't have good
randomized data
i think this is one of those things
where the burden
of evidence in the non-randomized data
is
so strong it's becoming hard to ignore
so most of the research on this subject
has come out of finland
and the lobbyists yeah um
and so there's the obvious issues with
this right the people who can afford
dasana
are by definition gonna have more time
on their hands more disposable income
probably more education like all of the
standard
uh things on top of that if you're gonna
choose to sauna because you believe it's
healthy
what else are you doing because you
believe it is healthy i mean
right so so you know if if the data
showed that
sauna versus non-sauna was like a five
percent improvement in mortality it
would be hard to get that excited about
it
but when you look at the largest
published series on this
you see a benefit in all cause mortality
a relative absolute pardon me a relative
risk reduction of 40 percent
and an absolute risk reduction of like
those are those are high numbers those
are ridiculous numbers
and that's when you um are comparing
someone who owns like saunas four to
seven times a week
i was going to ask yeah so what's the
dose and frequency the yeah yeah what's
the discretion what do you believe the
minimum effective dose to be kind of
like the zone two training you described
what it is
and then you said that yes i do four
times 45
just to get to the punch line i i think
based on the research the med
is four sessions 20 minutes
80 degrees celsius four sessions
times 20 minutes 80 degrees celsius yep
oh you fahrenheit what's the conversion
there i should have
that's about 175 fahrenheit 175
fahrenheit
got it dry wet
there's much more literature on dry you
know i actually had a call with a
patient this morning and this topic of
saunas came up
and she asked if she could substitute
steam rooms and such
and i said we just don't know because we
don't have the data
so the you know the precautionary
principle would say if you have access
to a dry sauna
that's where we have reams and reams and
reams of data
so it's probably where it goes but look
if you think about what the mechanism of
action is yeah i was going to ask you
next is it heat shock proteins is it
something else i think it's many things
i think it's heat chuck proteins i think
it's nitric oxide i think it's like
literally vascular tone
right reduction in blood pressure um
it's an it's like you know increase in
heart rate and cardiac output so there's
a bit of an exercise
benefit um i don't know if bdnf i think
bdnf has been measured i can't recall
that could be another
uh potential benefit so my guess is ddnf
brain derived neurotransmitter perfect
factor
yeah i think it's probably half a dozen
things that are all moving in the right
direction
um it's funny when i have done some
sauna ing
i've done lactate checks in there to see
if it gets me to la
zone two it's not so it's not a pure
exercise memetic because it doesn't even
get me to the level of a zone two
workout
at least when it comes to a pure you
know adp atp
uptake or atp production standpoint but
yeah i've become like really optimistic
on this and i think
it's uh i think it's very promising and
i think it's again it's the challenge is
how scalable is it right like it's not
as it's not that easy to do
i would imagine also contraindicated for
a lot of folks yeah
yeah i suspect you know if you're if
you're really far down the line of
your health is is suffering and you're
you know particularly old or something
like that
or your heart's a little more frail yeah
this would this might push you a little
bit beyond so again it speaks to sort of
prevention and
and hopefully with covid kind of winding
its way down and enough people getting
vaccinated people can get back to gyms
where saunas are and things like that
yeah amazing preferred method for
zone two training seems like you do most
of your work on a bike
i do i like the bike it's just my body
is so much more efficient on a bike than
anything else
do you have a preferred stationary bike
or do you i
i do i ride my bike like my road bike
on something called a wahoo kicker which
is
awesome like hands down if someone
doesn't have
a road bike then i my favorite
stationary bike
is the kaiser k-a-i-s-e-r
yeah k-a-i-s-e-r i believe and i think
kaiser makes such a fantastic
uh spin bike amazing you want to do
one more change your mind about or one
more excited
you can uh dealer's choice yeah i'm
pretty excited about glp-1 agonists
me too i don't even know what that means
tell me peter all right so
glp 1
agonist glucagon like peptide 1
they also go by glp1 ras
so glucagon peptide one receptor agonist
okay so glucagon is a hormone it's made
by the liver
sort of opposes the action of insulin
it's a it's a hormone that
um produces satiety um
and uh can regulate blood glucose levels
so regulate meaning it's catabolic
lowers lowers blood glucose
it secretes insulin actually it results
in secretion of insulin to lower blood
glucose so
got it these are a group of drugs that
have been around for quite some time
also kind of a a high choice in people
with
type 2 diabetes a trial came out
i want to say 2014 showing
that one of these drugs was actually
also pretty good for weight loss in
non-diabetics
it didn't get a lot of traction the
effect size was
was reasonable but it wasn't great i
looked at it quite a bit because i
remember at the time i had a patient
who whose weight was really recalcitrant
it just
wasn't clear what it was going to take
to get her to help help her lose weight
and
i certainly am not a fan of stimulants
for weight loss um you know drugs like
phentermine can be somewhat effective
but they can also have their side
effects and be somewhat habit-forming
and we had sort of noodled this and
eventually we ended up trying this drug
it didn't really have that much of an
effect and i i kind of
sort of put it aside for a while until
about
six or seven months ago i was talking to
someone who had an early line of sight
into a trial
that was going to be published and they
said
you know they'd been using it clinically
a newer version of this drug
um it's called semiglutid the um
trade name is ozempic and they said
yeah you've got to see what this drug
can do like so the drug the dose that's
given for people with diabetes is
one milligram once a week so it's an
injectable drug so it's it comes in a
little pen
you you know shoot it in your gut or
your leg once a week one millimeter
muscular or tiny tiny little insulin
syringe
and he said yeah but when we push people
up to two and a half milligrams
the weight loss is comical like and this
is not this is not just people with
diabetes this is anybody
and then sure enough there was a study
that was published
um probably a couple of months ago
looking at semi-glutide in overweight
and obese people without diabetes
and the weight loss was through the moon
i mean it was you know we're talking
like 20 weight loss holy [ __ ]
um completely durable as long as you're
on the drug so then it begs the question
what happens when you come off the drug
um we haven't seen fully what that looks
like yet i mean i think we need to see
what those studies look like i mean my
my thinking of this we've now put a lot
of patience on this drug
a lot is relative but you know maybe
maybe
12 15 patients we've put on this drug
some people can't tolerate it
because of the nausea so nausea yeah i
mean that's definitely one of those
effects is it administered once a week
once a week
uh is the nausea transient or is it yeah
it tends to
fluctuate how far you are you ha so if
you inject it on a sunday
and then you know usually by the next
saturday the symptoms are gone but then
when you hit yourself
on that sunday sunday monday tuesday
you'll be a bit more nauseous
now again that's so it's transient
across the week but it also seems to be
transient over time so
the the dose in the study was 2.4
milligrams so
you know two and a half times higher
than you're doing it in people with
type 2 diabetes but um you don't start
people at that dose you'll start them at
half a milligram for a few weeks
then one milligram then one and a half
then two etc
but basically we haven't seen any
patient who can tolerate the drug
that does not lose weight have any
cycled off
in which case i mean obviously behavior
matters a lot
and calories matter a lot but do you see
a greater no i don't even anticipate
otherwise
and they don't seem to regain all the
weight they lost now my
biggest concern and it means i was so
fascinated by this
uh before the study came out we actually
did a whole journal club just on this
study
and went like stupidly nerdy on this
drug
um the biggest concern i would have is
is a drug that lowers glucose but raises
insulin such a good idea um and also
it flies in the face of how you would
lose weight
in that situation right it seems to not
be entirely clear
why would that result in weight loss
unless the increase in insulin along
with the
glucagon-like peptide are reducing
appetite but what we've discovered
in experimenting with a lot of our
patients by experimenting i mean just
doing a lot of
blood tests before and after is
while it probably slightly increases
your fasting
insulin level it's also clearly
increasing
muscle insulin sensitivity because
postprandial insulin levels seem to be
down
and i would bet though it was not done
in this study postprandial meaning
post-meal after meal
i would bet that if they had looked at
24-hour insulin secretion
which you can do by collecting 24 hours
of urine
and measuring c-peptide which is
exists in a one-to-one ratio with
insulin because when insulin comes out
it's a pro-hormone
and then it gets cleaved into insulin
and c-peptide so
you should have one c-peptide for every
insulin so if you measure the urinary
amount of c-peptide you know how much
insulin was secreted i'm really
disappointed that study didn't do that
but my guess would be that they saw
24-hour c-peptide go down even as
resting insulin went up okay which would
mean
and well please correct me from
oversimplifying this but that
on if you look at the average it is not
net net leading you to increased insulin
levels
that's right yeah that's so interesting
yeah
this drug is current you've seen 20 now
when you say 20
reductions are we talking about body fat
or body weight
or body weight wow yeah total body
weight yeah
wow so you know that's and that's easy
there you'll see
more yeah these are in obese people yeah
we've even put it we've even had
patients who are not even wouldn't be
classified as obese just slightly
overweight you know a 200 pound person
but in three months is 180 pounds
and effortlessly at 180 pounds
right like they've literally reduced
their appetite um and they've improved
their insulin sensitivity
and glucose and that's where other
interventions failed so it's it's not
i mean i i know we're not blinding this
or anything with patients but
you don't think that that you you
attribute that predominantly to
this this drug not to say
changes in eating or other habits well
they have changed their eating but i
think it's in response to the drug
uh yeah right so i think the drug is
working
centrally peripherally i think it's
working on the fat cells i think it's
working on their
brain i think it's working on their
muscles i think it's doing a lot of
things
and it's still early days but i mean
this is a promising drug
in my opinion um you know i look i think
i think there are
there's there's some people who think
that you shouldn't need a drug to help
you
and like if you need a drug to lose
weight you're somehow a bad person or
something like that but you know i just
i just think categorically that's just
such a
simple-minded view of the world right
like we live in a world with technology
and just as you don't rub two sticks
together when you want to have a fire if
a zippo lighter is available to you
um you know if you have tried every
dietary strategy imaginable
and your metabolism is not you know
moving in the right direction
why shouldn't we explore other ways to
kick-start that and the other thing by
the way is i think you can take these
things for a few months
come off them and see if you have formed
new habits
in the interim um i also think they'll
be
in my mind a model for cycling three
months on three months off three months
on three months off again
we want to make sure that that doesn't
cause some recalcitrance to the
medication or something like that
um i think this is exciting i think this
warrants a lot more follow-up
but what it's saying is that
things that improve diabetes also
improve health
and nothing does that more than exercise
and nutrition that's the reality of it
but not everybody can do enough exercise
and the right nutrition with enough ease
to get the benefits so
the more tools we have in our toolkit
that go outside of that the better
dig it peter always so fun to hang
and i want to underscore
to me how exciting and interesting it is
for people listening
to strive to increase their scientific
literacy and you have your series of
articles
which we'll put in the show notes
there's a book that i enjoy
tremendously called bad science by ben
goldacre
i believe is an md and i
enjoyed that so much that had a few
excerpts from that book put into the
appendix or the appendices of
for our body because i wanted to provide
some basics are there any other
resources or recommendations
for folks who want to improve
their ability to separate fact from
fiction
hype from reality when it comes to
headlines media studies and so on i mean
not not to
get to peter tea level but to get to the
point where they just
have a better ability to separate signal
from noise with this kind of thing
you know there's a good newsletter that
i subscribe to out of the university of
indiana
um it's called the i think it's called
metabolomics and energetics or
metabolism and energetics it's like a
weekly newsletter that comes out on
fridays
and it's you know it's pretty detailed
but one of the sections
is always headline versus study and
that's that's always a cute one because
every
week you get to see they just pick one
example because of course there's a
billion examples every week of how
the headline says something and it turns
out to have nothing
in common with the study now that's not
exactly the question you've asked but it
is a good illustration of
just how basically just because you
if you read something in the media it's
you should just assume it's in it's
being taken out of context and it's
incorrect
um and unfortunately i i wish i had
better answers on
well it would be like if you saw a
headline that said eating nubbins
increases risk of colorectal cancer by
but if the chance is one in 10 billion
people and it goes to two and 10 billion
people
it's a great doesn't mean you should pay
attention to that's right and that's a
great discredit you're nubbin
and yeah that's a great example of
always knowing absolute risk versus
relative risk that's exactly that's
exactly like the kind of stuff we talk
about in studying studies is
never pay attention to relative risk
without knowing absolute risk as well
and things like that so yeah
peter i think it might be time for us to
prepare for
our uh prandial adventure that's
probably not the way you use it
to have our meal uh to have our happer
our pre-prandial exploration our
pre-perennial exploration
of uh various various cacti is agave
considered a cacti well i guess
what is mezcal actually made from is it
agave
um i know it's like a cubic fire in your
mouth
but that doesn't tell us much about the
botanical origins i know septol is
different
have you had cetol as a side note it's a
plant
or i should say it's a also it's a
beverage maybe it isn't a plant but it's
only found
in a few parts of texas and mexico and
it's sort of
in between tequila and mezcal
speaking of texas can i tell you the
only thing so far about texas i'm not
fond of
uh scorpions in your kitchen
i've only found that that was that was
this morning in my household
took care of it was fine um it's the
cactuses
when i'm out in the bush so when i was
out what are you doing out in the bush
well when i was out doing that precision
shooting
a couple months ago they were like
training for your counter sniper
operation that's right so we had like
mats down
on the ground and we're laying on our
mats and we're you know shooting off
into the distance and i
i vaguely remember someone saying stay
on your mat
oh god and um so at one point i'm like
loading my magazine and i kind of rolled
off the map
and you know loaded it and was shooting
and then
like that day we're driving home and i'm
like god why does my butt hurt
so much and why does my leg hurt so much
and you know by the time i got home i
realized i was just
full of these little micro needles and
it went through my pants everything and
i mean this is how you know
your wife really loves you because like
i had to give her a set of tweezers
to literally start yanking these needles
out of my butt
and my leg and i actually still have
some there
three months later i still i can still
feel some of the ones that broke beneath
it
and and so i'm going on this hunt in um
about three weeks
and it's my first time hunting access
deer here in texas
and one of the things that the guy who's
taking me said is you you got to make
sure your shoes
uh won't get poked like the cactus is
wanting to go through your boots you're
not going to wear your ninja socks for
this one yeah no this will not be a
barefoot huh
but aside from the cactuses man yeah
yeah
all good in the republic of texas i have
a shirt
maybe i'll get you one of these you
might have seen it it says
has a big flag texan flag on it says
most likely to secede yeah
they saw those at the airport in austin
for those who are interested
uh well peter off to dinner we go thanks
again is there anything that you would
like
to mention before we close of course
people can find you
peter atiyah md will basically take them
to everything i would imagine
that's the website that's twitter it's
instagram facebook
also youtube so you've been very
consistent
with uh how people can reach you
the podcast is the drive which
as mentioned is a weekly deep dive
podcast focusing on
uh all of the nerdy subjects
that i find so fascinating that peter
and his guests
know so much about anything you'd like
to add to that
i mean i would just say that some
decaffeinated brands of coffee are just
as tasty as the real thing
you know what their reference is what
movie is that from i don't get the
reference
what is that is that real genius i think
it's real is that real genius
you know i'll give you a bit of austin
trivia uh
we're going all over the show here but
uh there is
a food truck here in austin which
i had been told by a former professional
tennis player i had to try it had the
best
chicken wings and for me the chicken
wings in general are kind of like the
uh the pistachios of the fowl
family they're just so much work and you
don't get much out of it
turns out tommy want wingy which is the
name of this food truck
has incredible chicken wings they're
delicious i don't know
what anabolics they give these chickens
but they're
enormous uh you can have a full meal and
tommy want wingy where's your tommy want
wingy do you know he's he's actually at
uh i think it's cosmic cafe they may
have multiple locations
do you know what reference tommy want
wingy is from
well it's not the donger need food
that's 16 candles
tommy boy chris farley tommy want wingy
the diner scene it's funny i've seen
that movie 100 times how have i missed
that oh yeah yeah where he's talking
about his
his sales process and he convinces them
to the the waitress to
fire up the kitchen after they've closed
and he grabs i think it's like a muffin
and he's like
let's say that's my prospect and he
walks through this entire thing we'll
link
we'll link to this video in the show
notes
so that for us for people who want us to
get chris farley
plus zone two training plus rapamycin in
one place this is
probably the only site on the internet
that will have all of those
in one set of show notes and uh
peter thanks for taking the time man
thanks man
could you just briefly explain what
efficiency means
within the aerobic efficiency and then
come back to the zone 2 training
yeah it comes down to basically
substrate usage
so in um in aerobic activity
um you can use glucose or fat
those are basically the two fuels that
um
the body with oxygen can turn into atp
so aerobic most people will recognize
means
with oxygen and anaerobic means without
oxygen
so when you're not demanding much energy
of yourself and energy of course we talk
about is atp so atp is the currency for
energy
when your body isn't demanding much
energy you can
make atp using glucose or using fatty
acids
and it's a similar process but obviously
different because they're different
molecules so glucose
gets turned into something called
pyruvate and that happens in the cell
but outside of the mitochondria
and then the pyruvate gets shuttled into
the mitochondria
where it undergoes a process known as
the electron transport chain
where a whole bunch of chemical
reactions occur
that basically generate a gradient of
electrons
in the inner membrane of the
mitochondria that's ultimately
used um to produce carbon dioxide and
water and a boatload of atp
with fatty acids it's a little different
uh fatty acids
get broken down into smaller chunks of
fatty acids that have two carbons called
acetyl coa
and the acetyl coas get fed into the
mitochondria and undergo
the same sort of process so um
what's nice about that is you have the
ability to use both fuels
but when energy demands start to climb
so when you are asking more of yourself
when you're now
running or when you're walking up a
flight of stairs or doing anything that
now
the body's saying hey i need more and
more atp that glucose system is the
first one to cave
so the glucose system when you turn the
glucose into pyruvate
it basically says i don't have enough
oxygen
to run this through the mitochondria to
do what i need
i'm going to instead turn pyruvate into
lactate
which yields some atp but a pittance
compared to what it could do
so you know pyruvate into lactate will
generate 1 16
the atp that it would if it went into
the krebs cycle
which is horrible but it's like any port
in a storm right it's like i don't have
a choice
as a side note everybody tends to think
that lactate is what causes the soreness
when you're
doing that it's actually not the lactate
it's hydrogen it's the hydrogen ion that
accompanies the
the lactate because lactate is acidic so
you don't actually feel anything from
the lactate and lactate itself is
actually a pretty remarkable fuel the
brain
there's emerging evidence that the brain
actually likes lactate as a fuel
and the liver can turn it back into
glucose pretty easily
but nevertheless it's inefficient right
it's a horrible way to turn your
hydrocarbon into atp
and it does come with this problem of
being self-limited
so the efficiency speaks to the longer
you can use the mitochondria the better
and this zone two characteristic
is really one of the most remarkable
ways to separate and differentiate
people
with different degrees of metabolic
efficiency so um inigo
san milan and george brooks did a study
that i talked about at length in one of
the amas
do you say caesar milan i'm kidding the
dog trainer
yeah were the names again inigo okay son
milan
and george brooks inigo has been a guest
on my podcast as well
they did a study looking at three
cohorts of people professional cyclists
fit people and people with type 2
diabetes just real quick how did they
define fit
um i don't remember exactly but it would
be like people who exercise
a certain number of hours a week who
were pretty fit these were people that
were probably exercising 10 hours a week
or something to that effect
so so not just kind of like weekend 10
hours a week is not trivial no no not at
all right
and what they looked at was what were
their lactate
curves um on a bicycle
and at what point did they reach that
two millimole level
and you know it's just a staggering
difference
so all of them would ultimately achieve
high lactates admittedly very different
powers right the fitter you are the
more power you generate before you hit
that peak lactate
the people with type 2 diabetes were
reaching
this critical threshold at something in
the vicinity of
80 to 100 watts um so 80 to 100 watts on
a bike if you don't know what that feels
like
um it's hard to explain what that would
i wish i had a good conversion for what
that feels like
that's not a lot of effort uh i guess
for someone who spends
time on ground yeah flat ground no wind
going 13 or 14 miles an hour got it
maybe less which amounts to about 1.2
watts per kilo because you always want
to normalize these things to body weight
so 1.2 watts per
kilo one watt per kilo in that vicinity
the the reasonably well trained average
you know not average
reasonably well trained person um
was hitting that number at closer to 150
to 170 watts
uh putting them pretty comfortably in
about the 1.7
1.8 watt per kilo range so
you know significantly higher than
people type 2 diabetes and the
professional cyclists were hitting that
mark
in the vicinity of 320
to 360 watts and of course they're even
lighter
so they're hitting that number at a
staggering 4 watts per kilo
what was the total duration of the
assessment
it's typically done you you know unlike
a ramp test where you're quickly quickly
changing you you typically do long ramps
so
you know 15 minutes check lactate 15
minutes check lactate or 10 minutes
would be about the minimum
do you think those results would have
looked different
had the muscle groups involved been
different
had it been uh like a hand bike or
something like that i guess i'm
wondering if there's any localized
effect just given the training of the
cyclist
yeah it's possible um and and certainly
there's a you know there's an efficiency
that comes
from doing the thing that you're being
tested on
typically lower body exercises are the
way to do this because we have so
much muscle mass there when we have
patients do their zone two we basically
recommend three things you know a bike
a rowing machine or a treadmill are
probably the best ways to to get that
and it doesn't have to be running i mean
when i do
to get you mean to assess or to also
train both both yeah
because it does need to be pretty steady
state so
you know hiking up and down steep climbs
tends to not be a great form of training
for this that's another type of training
but when you're coming in and out and in
and out of zone two it's not the same as
sort of planting yourself there
staying there and forcing your
mitochondria to adapt to it that was
actually gonna be my next question so
what is the
adaptation that one hopes for like what
is actually happening to the body when
you do
effective zone two training so you're
increasing the ability of the
mitochondria
to utilize the substrate you're
increasing the ability of the muscle to
actually take in more
oxygen so um it's really funny when you
compare a really fit person to a really
unfit person and so think about
something like a vo2 max test
um everybody's breathing the same amount
of oxygen
so let's imagine for a moment that you
are you know
the fittest guy in the world and i am
not we're both sitting in this room
we're both
breathing in 21 oxygen
if you then put us on a bike and make us
go as hard as possible
and measure how much oxygen is coming
out you'll notice that much less
oxygen is coming out of you than me so
the difference is you're able to use
more oxygen than i am
and that is probably not
um mediated at the level of your lungs
that's probably more mediated at the
level of your muscles
now there may be some differences in the
lung as well this is not an entirely
settled question but there's undoubtedly
a bigger delta at the muscles
so that's a big part of it is simply
being able to utilize more
oxygen the other thing is
perhaps increasing the density of
mitochondria so simply having more
mitochondria
in the muscle will allow for more of
that substrate to enter the mitochondria
versus
outside and then of course there are
transporters
and the transporters determine a little
bit of how the body
can sort of utilize lactate keep it in
the cell
versus recycle it and get it out of the
cell quicker
from a training standpoint the good news
is all of this stuff
is trainable but it does require
deliberate
form of training and one thing i don't
think we know yet but it's looking like
the minimum effective dose
is probably about three hours a week um
three hours
yeah ideally delivered at sort of 45 to
60 minute intervals
um i've asked indigo about this
specifically you know would
just as a thought experiment with doing
a whole bunch of 15-minute sets a week
be sufficient
his view is it would not be that it
probably needs to be at least 45 minutes
per session so you could do say four
i do 4 45s these days
as my zone 2 protocol at times i've done
more there's times i'm doing four
60 minute sessions a week and those
should feel
if i'm remembering correctly from what
you said earlier
those should not feel agonizing
these should be kind of sustained
all-day hike type of i know the hike
isn't exactly
perfect but assuming it's it's a say
flat ground constant load
this this should be something you could
sustain for much longer than say 45
minutes
that's right and the not all not all of
our patients want to use a lactate test
so i lactate test myself every time i do
a zone two test
so i have so unlike you peter right
right so for three years i have
every session i've ever done recorded by
power
heart rate lactate all of that stuff
because you do see variation by the way
so a given power doesn't always keep me
at the same zone too so how well i slept
the night before
my state of hydration what i've eaten
will all impact this
but how are you tracking whether you are
in zone 2 or not
by poking my finger yep i'm using that
okay so when people don't want to do
that what do we recommend well we
recommend
figuring out what your zone 2 heart rate
is because you can track heart rate
really easily
so rectal probe most of the time exactly
no that's for temperature
so um so heart rate depends on how long
it is right so
[Music]
[Laughter]
just sitting right there on the vena
cave um so
you know with with heart rate you want
to give somebody a starting point so so
one option is you tell people to do a
little bit of lactate testing maybe test
yourself
once a month figure out what your heart
rate is and then going forward just rely
on heart rate
for people who never ever ever want to
poke themselves or
just are insulted by how expensive these
stupid things are which they are really
stupidly expensive like the
lactate meter is 250 bucks but the
strips are four dollars apiece
so nice which is just so aggravating
because you know these things cost about
12 cents to make we usually use
two ways of estimating one estimate is
180 minus your age
which i think is the low estimate um
right so a 50 year old would you start
them at about 130
130 what beats per minute beats per
minute
another way to estimate it is if you
know your maximum heart rate
so this is usually for people who
exercise quite a bit with a heart rate
monitor
and they know what their true maximum
heart rate is
so let's say a person's out there and
they can say they say you know what i
can achieve
178 beats per minute just before i feel
like i'm going to keel over
that's your max heart rate i usually
start people at about
78 of max heart rate
now again the next thing we layer on
that is
the sort of the litmus test of how do
you feel
are you able to almost carry out a
conversation
when you're doing the activity and the
answer should be yes but i don't really
want to
that's that's about the sweet spot so
it's like a it's a strained conversation
but you could do it yeah like yesterday
i was doing my zone two
and my dad called and i missed a bunch
of his calls normally i don't answer
the phone when i'm on the bike because i
have a fan that is blowing air on me so
much and it's so noisy but i answered
the phone anyway so you know i talked to
my dad for five minutes which mostly
meant i let him talk
and i was kind of like grunting a little
bit yeah uh-huh yeah okay
yeah but i wouldn't want to do this
on my bike for a zone two like this
would be a bit more than i'd want to do
and if you can't talk at all which you
wouldn't be able to talk of course if
you're doing like a zone five
uh then you know you're obviously going
too hard
and the the long-term benefit just to
reiterate
the long-term benefit of doing
zone two training for say a minimum
uh effective dose of three hours per
week
is what and when can someone expect to
start to see adaptations that are
beneficial
well the latter is a good question
because it probably depends on from
where you start
right so um you know with with someone
who's starting out really metabolically
broken which by definition is what type
2 diabetes is that's the most extreme
example we have of completely broken
metabolism right so a complete inability
to partition fuel
almost a complete inability to burn
fatty acids
which again gets back to your question
about efficiency an efficient engine
should be able to run on two fuels
it should be able to run on glucose and
it should be able to run on fat a broken
engine can
only run on the short-term fuel which is
glucose
and that's a that's a brutal cycle to be
in right if you can
only run on glucose you're you're in
you're going to be in a tough
situation because we can store such a
tiny amount of glucose relative to fat
and you're going to be at the mercy of
fluctuating glucose levels
constantly whereas if you can rely on
fat you're better off
i've seen um people make adaptations to
this
um you know i would usually say it takes
three to six months to start to see some
adaptations
um i guess over the past two and a half
years my
zone two power has gone up
by 25
power measured by watts yeah and to be
honest it's still below
what it was nine years ago or seven
years ago when i was
training as a cyclist so even though i
didn't think of this type of training as
a cyclist i would do these types of
workouts as an important part of my
overall training
and i was just infinitely fitter back
then so my zone two back then
was i mean probably 40 watts higher than
it is now
although my zone two is probably 40
watts higher now than it was two and a
half years ago
you